GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
ONE TWO THREE FOUR.
GOOD MORNING MR WILL OBERNOLTE.
WELCOME TO THE.
WHAT IS TODAY APRIL TWENTY
FIFTH HEARING OF THE ELECTIONS
ARE DISTURBING COMMITTEE BEFORE
BEGIN HAVE A COUPLE OF
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS TO
MAKE?
FIRST OF A LETTER FROM THE
SPEAKER POINTING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JAY OBERNOLTE TO REPLACE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC STEINORTH
ON THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
PURPOSES OF TODAY'S HEARING
ONLY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US.
SECOND WE HAVE AN UPDATE ON THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
OBERNOLTE.
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
AND WILL NOT BE HEARD. AT
TODAY'S HEARING.
AND WITH THAT SAID MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL BERMAN HERE BERMAN HERE
HARPER.
CALDERON CALDERON HERE LOW.
MULLIN.
MULLIN HERE OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE
HERE WEBER.
WEBER HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
GREAT SO THEY'RE EIGHTEEN BILLS
UP IN OUR COMMITTEE TODAY THREE
BELLS ITEM NUMBER TEN ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN IN ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN ARE PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. THAT OF THE BILLS THAT
ARE UP IN COMMITTEE WILL GET YOU
IN A MINUTE.
BUT SHOULD WE GO AHEAD AND.
MAKE THEM DRIVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT. I HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
ON ITEMS NUMBER TEN ELEVEN AND
EIGHTEEN.
DOES ANY MEMBER WAS TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
NO GREAT I'M I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE OVERALL FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
BERMAN HERE I AYE BERMAN AYE
HARPER.
CALDERON. CALDERON AYE LOW.
MULLIN. MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE WEBER.
WEBER I AND IN THE ABSENCE OF
ANY OTHER AUTHORS MISTER MULLIN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT.
YOUR THREE BILLS.
FIRST ITEM NUMBER NINE THEN
ITEM NUMBER FIVE THAT ITEM
NUMBER THREE
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PRESENTING AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE
THAT PUBLIC FACILITIES.
REMAIN AVAILABLE FOR USE AS VOTE
CENTERS THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT.
AS IMPLEMENTATION OF SP FOUR
FIFTY THE CALIFORNIA VOTERS
CHOICE ACT BEGINS THIS YEAR IN
MULTIPLE COUNTIES INCLUDING MINE
SAN MATEO COUNTY.
AS MORE COUNTIES TRANSITION OF
THE VOTES CENTER MODEL.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT ELECTIONS
ADMINISTRATORS HAVE AN ADEQUATE
POOL OF POTENTIAL LOCATIONS.
POR ELECTION DAY. IN THE EARLY
VOTING PERIOD WHILE FEWER
LOCATIONS WILL BE NEEDED ON
ELECTION DAY ITSELF THE NUMBER
OF LOCATIONS NEEDED DURING THAT
EARLY VOTING PERIODIS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED
UNDER THE SP FOUR FIFTY MODEL
PUBLIC FACILITIES.
INCLUDING SCHOOLS LIBRARIES
COMMUNITY CENTERS AND CITY HALLS
ARE IDEAL LOCATIONS FOR VOTES
CENTERS BEING THAT THEY ARE
QUICK WITH INTERNET AND WIFI
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY FOR
ELECTRONIC VOTING EQUIPMENT.
THEY ARE ACCESSIBLE AND VOTERS
ARE GENERALLY FAMILIAR WITH
WHERE THEY ARE LOCATED IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
SUCH FACILITIES HAVE
TRADITIONALLY SERVICE POLLING
PLACES UNDER THE CURRENT
ELECTION MODEL AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY WOULD INSURE THAT THE SAME
LOCATIONS REMAIN AVAILABLE
DURING THE EARLY VOTING. UNDER
THE NEW VOTES CENTER MODEL.
WITHOUT A RELIABLE POOL OF
AVAILABLE LOCATIONS ELECTIONS
ADMINISTRATORS MAY STRUGGLE THE
FIND ENOUGH LOCATIONS ARE HAVE
TO EXPEND SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
ON OTHER COMMERCIAL LOCATIONS.
TWENTY FIVE FORTY WILL PROVIDE
ELECTIONS ADMINISTRATORS WITH
MORE RESOURCES AND ULTIMATELY
MAKE CERTAIN THAT VOTERS HAVE
ACCESS TO VOTE CENTERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES WITH ME TODAY HAVE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY REGISTRAR
RECORDER COUNTY CLERK DIEM
LOGAN.
AS WELL AS PLASTER COUNTY CLERK
RECORDER REGISTAR RIGHT WRONG
CHO TO OFFER COMMENTARY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TIM ROEMER MULLIN AYE
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BERMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
DEAN LOGAN AND THE RED STAR
CARTER CAN CLICK FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. AND PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
AND ELECTION OFFICIALS I'M WE
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS BILL AND URGE THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
AS WAS STATED OF THIS REALLY
JUST EXTEND THE PROVISIONS THAT
ARE ALREADY IN EXISTENCE FOR
PUBLIC FACILITIES TO BE USED AS
POLLING LOCATIONS TO THEIR USE
FOR VOTE CENTERS UNDER THE
VOTERS CHOICE ACT AND SO. THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT REALIZING THE
BENEFITS OF THE VOTER CHOICE ACT
IN ENSURING THAT WE HAVE TO SELL
THESE THAT ARE ACCEPTABLE
CONVENIENT AND VISIBLE FOR
VOTERS WHEN WE MOVE TO TO THIS
MODEL. AS YOU ALL KNOW THERE'S
GROWING PRESSURE FOR ELECTION
ADMINISTRATORS THE CALIFORNIA TO
SECURE LOCATIONS FOR POLLING
PLACES ABOUT SENATE'S. UNLIKE
POLLING PLACES
TO GENERALLY OPEN ONLY ONE DAY
UNDER THE VOTERS CHOICE ACT WE
ARE LOOKING FOR LOCATIONS
CONSENT CASES WILL BE OPEN FOR
ELEVEN DAYS OTHERS THAT WILL BE
OPEN FOR FOUR DAYS. LEADING UP
TO ELECTION DAY AND OBVIOUSLY
PUBLIC FACILITIES THAT ARE
VISIBLE ON FAMILIAR TO PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY ARE PRIME
LOCATIONS FOR THAT AND THAT AND
WE JUST WANT TO BE SURE THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO USE THOSE AND
MAKE THEM AVAILABLE TO THE
VOTERS THAT WE URGE YOUR.
SUPPORT.
HI GOOD MORNING THAT THANK YOU
SUPPLEMENT MULLIN.
MEMBERS I RYAN RONCO I'M THAT
CLASS COUNTY CLERK MODERATES ARE
VOTERS AND I AM CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF QUICK
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS THAT
LEGISLATION COMMITTEE. AGAIN
JUST THAT TAG ON TO IT GUY DEAN
SAID.
WE ARE AT NEW TRANSITIONING
INTO A NEW WAY OF HANDLING A
VOTING.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE LOCATIONS THAT ARE
VISIBLE THAT ARE ACCESSIBLE AND
WERE AS CERTAINLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO AVOID. THIS BILL
BEING PASSED THAT WE CAN BE ABLE
TO MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
EVELYN ADOLESCENT DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WHEN I AM
EXTEND OUR SUPPORT AND THINK THE
OTHERS OFFICE FOR WORKING WITH
US ON AMENDMENT TO ENSURE
ACCESSIBILITY FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DOROTHY JOHNSON AT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES PLEASED TO BE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ISHAM ONTO LONG ON
BEHALF OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE
ALEX BILLION SPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
RAIN HICKS CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHTS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU READY.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NOW BRING BACK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE.
MISTER MALONE WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK TRAVEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I DON'T
THINK.
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD THIS BILL WILL HELP
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS LOCATE
BUILDINGS TO USES POINT PLACES
AND VOTE CENTERS THAT ARE COST
EFFECTIVE AND ACCESSIBLE TO VOTE
TO ALL VOTERS. WHICH IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN COUNTIES
THAT ARE CONDUCTING ELECTIONS
AND OF THE CALIFORNIA VOTED
VOTERS CHOICE ACT SINCE VOTE
CENTERS ARE REQUIRED TO BE OPEN
FOR UP TO ELEVEN DAYS. AND FOR
THESE REASONS I WILL BE
RECOMMENDING A SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOST IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE BERMAN
AYE HARPER.
HARPER NOT VOTING CALDERON.
LOW.
LOW AYE MULLIN AYE MULLIN AYE
OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
IT'S THAT'S OUT AND WE'LL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND MISS MONEY YOU WANT TO.
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE ON
THE AGENDA.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT.
YES MISTER CHAIR PRESENTING
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT THE
SOCIAL MEDIA DISCLOSE ACT WHICH
HAS GENERATED A BIT OF A CROWD
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS.
I AS MOST OF YOU KNOW THE BILL I
AUTHORED LAST YEAR A. B. TWO
FOUR NINE THE CALIFORNIA
DISCLOSE ACT WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW.
AB TWO FORTY NINE MADE STRIDES
IN ADDRESSING LACKS CAMPAIGN
FINANCE DISCLOSURE REGULATIONS
POLITICAL ADS ARE NOW REQUIRED
TO WE HERE AT HERE TO NEW
FORMATTING EARMARKING
REGULATIONS MAKING IT EASIER.
FOR VOTERS TO KNOW WHO THE TRUE
FUNDERS ARE BEHIND ADVERTISEMENT
STACEY. AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT THE SOCIAL MEDIA DISCLOSE
ACT WILL SIMPLY EXTEND THOSE NEW
CAMPAIGN FINANCE DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS TO POLITICAL ADS
APPEARING ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS.
AS MOST OF US ARE WELL AWARE
WITH INCREASING FREQUENCY PEOPLE
ARE GETTING THEIR NEWS AND
INFORMATION VIA SOCIAL MEDIA. AS
A RESULT SUCH SITES ARE BECOMING
A MAJOR LOCATION FOR THE
PLACEMENT OF POLITICAL ADS AS
VOTERS ARE EXPOSED TO POLITICAL
ADVERTISEMENTS WHILE THEY SCROLL
THROUGH THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA
FEEDS.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS ALSO APPLIED ADS
APPEARING ON THESE ONLINE
PLATFORMS.
TRANSPARENCY IS NEEDED FOR ALL
POLITICAL ADS REGARDLESS OF THE
MANNER IN WHICH THEY APPEAR TO
VOTERS
WE'VE HAD VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM FACEBOOK
AND OTHER SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT
IN PRINCIPLE WITH VARIOUS
REPRESENTATIVES OF SOCIAL MEDIA
ON THE SUBSTANTIVE ASPECTS.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT.
EACH OF YOU WILL FIND A COPY OF
MOCK AMENDMENTS THESE ARE
AMENDMENTS THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
PRODUCT OF ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
I'VE BEEN HAVING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN.
AS WELL AS FACEBOOK AND THE
INTERNET ASSOCIATION. THEY WERE
SHARED WITH COMMITTEE STAFF AS
WELL AND I'M COMMITTED TO TAKING
THESE AMENDMENTS AFTER TODAY'S
HEARING MOVING FORWARD I WANT TO
THANK ETHAN JONES IN PARTICULAR
YOUR COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR
ALL OF HIS WORK. ON THIS ISSUE
AND PAST ISSUES I'M SURE IT'S
BEEN A CHALLENGE SO WITH ME
TODAY. IS TRENT LYING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
OFFER ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT.
AT THAT THANK YOU ARE GOOD
MORNING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
FIRST WOULD LIKE TO VERY MUCH
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE IN
GENERAL SPECIFICALLY ON THIS
BILL AND FOLLOWING UP ON THE
CALIFORNIA DISCLOSE ACT. ARM AS
HE DESCRIBED IT AS A CRUCIAL
FOLLOW UP TO DISCLOSE ACT TO
DISCLOSE THAT FOCUSED ON THE
PROBLEM OF MAKING COMMITTEES.
DISCLOSE THEIR TOP THREE
FUNDERS.
ON THE ALL THE DIFFERENT KINDS
OF BAD TELEVISION AND RADIO A A
PRINT.
DENT ON SOME ELECTRONIC MEDIA
IT'S BUT IT'S A. AND WHEN IT
COMES TO SOCIAL MEDIA THAT
REALLY THE PLAY HAVE TO BE THE
PLATFORMS THAT MAKE THE
DISCLOSURES BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT CAN.
GIVE THE TECHNOLOGY A A A THE
WAY TO MAKE IT WORK SO BEEN VERY
PLEASED TO HAVE VERY PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH A FACEBOOK AND
INTERNET ASSOCIATION AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MOMENTS THAT SAID. VERY.
PLEASED TO HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH.
ETHAN IS YOUR CONSULTANT.
I'M I THINK WERE IN A VERY GOOD
PLACE HERE ERRORS NINETEEN
ORGANIZATIONS.
IN IN SUPPORT OF THIS SOME OF
WHOM ARE HERE PLUS A A LARGE
NUMBER THE PUBLICLY SUPPORTED
THE. CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS LIKE NOW
SUPPORT THE SOCIAL MEDIA SCHOOLS
ACTED WELL THANK YOU.
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS.
JACK Y. NORTH CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE WE WERE STRONG SUPPORTERS
OF LAST YEAR'S AB TWO FORTY NINE
THE CALIFORNIA DISCLOSE ACT.
AND WE THINK THAT AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT IS AN EFFECTIVE
FOLLOW UP THE POSTERS DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE BETTER.
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT WILL CREATE CLEAR
INFORMATIVE DISCLOSURES ON
SOCIAL MEDIA ADVERTISEMENTS
WHILE ALSO PROVIDING THE PUBLIC
WITH A CONVENIENT WAY TO SEE WHO
FUNDS THE CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE.
AND WHICH ADVERTISEMENTS THAT
COMMITTEES PAYING FOR A SO
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE STRONGLY
SUPPORTS AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT AND WE ARE TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
IF YOU DISAGREE BUT IF YOU JUST
A HIGH.
AND I'D SAY YOUR NAME.
ANY ORGANIZATION YOU'RE
REPRESENTING AND WHETHER YOU AND
AND WHETHER OR NOT YOU SUPPORT
THE BILL THANKS.
WHO'S MARATHON ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
PETER Y. NO CITIZEN FROM
OAKHURST CALIFORNIA AND SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AT VIRGINIA TO
SUPPORT THE BILL IN THANKING YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
HEATHER RANDOL MERCY WITH THE
WALNUT CREEK RESISTORS AND
CENTRAL CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
INDIVISIBLE I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
ROBERT PACKARD PENN VALLEY PARA
CALIFORNIA. PLEASE SUPPORT
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT WE
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU.
CHARLES SARGE I CHAIR OF HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIA AND.
BAY AREA PENINSULA AND DIRECTOR
OF HEALTH CARE FOR ALL OF IRAQ
CALIFORNIA.
I I ENTHUSIASTICALLY ARE URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
PAT LANG LASALLE TO SALES I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M BILL HILTON
SUNNYVALE CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
SUPPORT TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
AND I HOPE YOU WILL TOO THANK
YOU.
GORDON MILLER WALNUT CREEK MONEY
OUT PEOPLE AND COALITION
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL. I
WANT TO KNOW IF THAT PUTIN IS
PAYING FOR THE AD.
THANK YOU YOU NEED TO.
VAN RAINY LIVERMORE INDIVISIBLE
I JUST WANT TO KNOW WHO TO
TRUST.
THANKS.
CHRIS CHANNELS AND FROM BERKELEY
PLEASE SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER HAY FROM SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE SUPPORT BILL THANK YOU
THE.
SANDY ENDO ALBANY CALIFORNIA.
THESE ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MARY BELL SHAPE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK.
MARY ENCOURAGE FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIA I AM US.
THE OUR HEAD OF THE GOSPEL
JUSTICE COMMITTEE AT THINK JAMES
CATHOLIC CHURCH AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF BILL. TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU.
MAGILL STANFORD TO IN SUPPORT.
THEY ACOSTA
WITH THE MICROPHONE.
LIQUID WITH MICHAEL LEVINSON AND
SUPPORT.
AND I WILL SAY THIS WILL EXPAND
CALIFORNIA'S NATIONWIDE
LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GARY OF HEALTH A MILL VALLEY
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
AND HARVEY FROM OAKLAND AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANKS.
AND VICKI MEANWHILE VERA AND I
LIVE AND I'M SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M A MEMBER OF LEGAL OF
WOMEN VOTERS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THE BELT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GLORIA PURCELL BELMONT
CALIFORNIA I WITH THE GREEN
PARTY AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU I HOPE YOU WILL TOO.
THANK YOU.
PAVEL JOHNSON SAN JOSE PLEASE
SUPPORT THE BILL I THINK YOU'RE
VERY MUCH.
YOU NAME ELVIS SIRI POLO ALSO
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THE IS MALAY SACRAMENTO
REQUESTING A FAVORABLE DECISION
THANK YOU THANKS.
VICTORIA GOLDEN WITH THE
DISCLOSURE ACT.
FROM KERN COUNTY BAKERSFIELD
THANK YOU PLEASE WITH THE BILL
THANK YOU.
LYNDA CORNEILLE WHOLE MILL
VALLEY CALIFORNIA.
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET HUYDECOPER MENLO PARK.
SAY HI TO MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PAILIN FOR.
I HEARD ON THE RADIO THIS
MORNING A POLITICAL AD. WHERE
THEY TALKED ABOUT THE
ORGANIZATION AND SPECIAL
INTEREST GROUPS?
AND I'VE THIS WILL GET RID OF
THAT.
TERM BECAUSE THE SPECIAL
INTEREST YOU COULD BAY LOBBYISTS
CHEVRON OR NURSES.
SO THAT'S WHY SUPPORT.
CLEAN MONEY THINGS FUN.
A.
TIME LARRY BATHGATE FROM MILL
VALLEY CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN MULLIN
FOR SHEPHERDING THIS BILL AND
ALSO AB TWO FORTY NINE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KEVIN WOLF DAVIS.
THE KEY IS CLEARLY SHOWING THE
TOPIC FUNDERS.
THANK YOU.
I CAN MORE FIELD ANAHEIM HILLS
PLEASE SUPPORT FOR SOCIAL MEDIA
DISCLOSE ACT FIGURE VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING JULIE LA GRANGE
ROSE FELL STRONGLY URGE IN YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I CATHARINE CARPIO FROM LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA WHAT'S HE CMC
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY.
IF YOU.
DEE MARIE MILITARY FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND.
AS SOMEONE WHO GETS MOST OF FOR
INFORMATION FROM SOCIAL MEDIA I
IMPLORE THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING.
WILL GONZALEZ A MAP OF FACEBOOK
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR FOR
WORKING WITH US ON SOME
TECHNICAL ISSUES ARE HAS
PROPOSED BE MANY WE'RE GONNA BE
IT'S PART.
THANKS.
RIGHT NEXT CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHTS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CHERYL COLE SET SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOTHING F. PALO ALTO ME TO.
THANKS YEAH.
MARK CARLSON LUTHERAN OFF
SUPPOSE
POLICY ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SHERRI FITZGERALD VALLEJO
CALIFORNIA PLEASE SUPPORT AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DAVIS BUT SERVICES GO PLEASE
VOTE YES ON AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU.
JIM SO PER AUTHOR OF COUNTED AS
CAST IRON ORDER FROM CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IN A STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL NICK THANK
YOU.
JAMES PATTERSON FROM GILROY AYE
AYES PROMINENT SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CRAIG DUNKERLEY.
FROM SAN JOSE I ALSO SERVE ON
THE CITIZENS ADVISORY COMMISSION
ON ELECTIONS FOR SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. AND I'M THE LAST ME TO.
THANKS GREG.
THANK YOU EVERYONE THEN AND A
SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO EVERYONE
FROM THE TWENTY FOURTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OR TRAINERS.
COME ON UP.
WHEN CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE THANKS KEVIN MCKINLEY
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR FAIRS WITH INTERNET
ASSOCIATION.
JUST GRABBED MICHAEL OF THE BANK
OF THE AUTHORS OFFICE THE
SPONSOR AND COMMITTEE STAFF.
THINK OF DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB
GETTING THE BILL WHERE IT IS.
.
WE STILL HAVE SOME ONGOING
CONCERNS ABOUT THE.
MECHANICS AND SOME OF THE USER
INTERFACE THE WAY THAT. IT'S
LEGISLATED IN THE LANGUAGE AND
WE THINK THAT THE BIG ISSUES
SURROUNDING THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE ADVERTISER IN THE
PLATFORM WHICH REALLY THAT. THE
TOUGH STUFF IS WORKED OUT.
AND SO WE'RE VERY OPTIMISTIC
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET TO THE
PLACE ON THIS BILL WHICH NOT
QUITE THERE YET.
BUT AGAIN THANK YOU
GREAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES EITHER
NEUTRAL OR IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
WITH A MOTION AND A SECOND AND
I'LL BRING BACK TO COLLEGE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ABOUT
YOUR HARPER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AYE THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE A GROUPS THAT ADVERTISE
ON FACEBOOK OR TWITTER I TO
INCLUDE A LINK ON THEIR WILL ON
A WEB PAGE.
WHICH IS LINKED FROM THAT OUT
ITSELF.
WHICH SHOWS THAT THE OTHER ADS
FROM THE PAST YEAR IS WELL IT'S
INFORMATION FROM EACH THE OTHER
RATS INCLUDING TARGETED AUDIENCE
THE TARGET AUDIENCE.
NUMBER VIEWS AND THE AVERAGE
RATE CHARGE FOR THE ADD ON ONE
OF MY QUESTIONS WAS IS IS GOING
TO BE ABOUT. THIS ISN'T EVEN
REGARD BROUGHT REQUIRED OF.
PRINT ADVERTISEMENTS AURA OR
MAILERS OR SUCH BY THIS KIND OF
CATALOGING.
THAT'S.
REQUIRED FOR UP FOR FOLKS TO BE
ABLE TO OUT TO VIEW I IN FACT
CAMPAIGNS MAY BE TARGETING.
THEIR COMMUNICATION FROM ONE
GROUP VERSUS THE OTHER AYE
INTENDING IT TO BE TAILORED AND
SPECIFIC A TO THAT GROUP.
I SO SO THE QUESTION I REQUEST
I'M GONNA HAVE FIRST IS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHY FOR THIS AND NOT
FOR US. NOT FROM IN PRINT I IS
THIS MEANT TO BE PERMANENT AYE
IS THERE A TIME WHEN THE
CAMPAIGN OR THE SOCIAL MEDIA.
IS SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO.
TO PURGE THIS AYE IN WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE RESPONSIBLE FOR
KEEPING THAT CATALOGING IS THAT
THE SOCIAL MEDIA SITE OR IS IT
THE CANDIDATES.
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS THERE LET ME
LET ME TRY TO ADD A TACKLE THAT
THE TOP LINE HERE WHICH IS THERE
ARE REQUIREMENTS FOR MAINTAIN AS
AN ESSENTIALLY DATABASE A
TELEVISION OR RADIO MEDIA
COMPANIES.
WITH REGARD TO WHOSE PURCHASING
OUR ADVERTISEMENTS THIS WAS
SIMPLY APPLY THOSE SAME
REGULATIONS OF VIA THAT TWO
FORTY NINE AS IT APPLIED TO.
TELEVISION OR RADIO OF MEDIA TO
SOCIAL MEDIA BUT I WILL ALLOW
TRENT TO COMMENT ON YOUR
QUESTION AROUND PRINT MEDIA WHAT
SOME OF THE DISTINCTIONS ARE BUT
I THINK THAT.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT PIECE
OF THE BILL THAT DOESN'T.
YOU REALLY GET THE HEADLINES YA
THE TOP THREE FUNDERS FINDING
THE TRUTH.
DISCLSING THE TRUE FUNDERS AT
SO IT'S EASY FOR PEOPLE TO READ
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
FOR JOURNALISTS TO BE ABLE TO
CLICK AND SEE THAT IN AGGREGATE
WHO WHERE THE MONEY IS MOVING
AND SOCIAL MEDIA WHO'S TRYING TO
INFLUENCE ADVERTISEMENT SO I
THINK THIS IS A KEY PIECE OF THE
BILL BUT I WILL LET TRENT
ADDRESS SOME OF THE. PARTICULARS
WITH THAT QUESTION.
AT THANK YOU ARE ARMED YET THIS
IS A KEY PIECE OF THE BILL AS AS
WRITTEN DRAFT IS INTENDED TO BE
THE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS THAT
HAVE TO KEEP THE THAT THE
DATABASE.
.
THE BILL REQUIRES THEM TO HAVE A
A LINK ON THEIR ON THAT SO THAT
THE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM TO PUT
A VIEW ADS OR SIMILAR SORT OF
LINK. ON THE.
PROFILE PAID THAT THAT THEY HOPE
THEY DO THE LAYOUT PEOPLE
CONTENT BUT. FACEBOOK DOES THE
LAYOUT THAT WOULD GO TO THE
DATABASE OF ADS PAID FOR BY THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT IN FACT FACEBOOK IS.
PROPOSING TO ROLLOUTS A A
SIMILAR DATABASE NATIONWIDE FOR.
FOR.
ARE ALL ADVERTISING AND SO THIS
FITS IN KIND RIGHT EXACTLY
WITHOUT THAT APPLIED TO ALL
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
IF NOT THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
COMMITTEE TO KEEP THAT DATABASE
WOULD BE THIS RESPONSIBILITY THE
PLATFORM WHICH. FACEBOOK'S ARE
INTENDING TO DO.
SO ONE OF THE BIG QUESTIONS THAT
I HAVE IS.
IS THIS REALLY RESTRICTED TO
ONLY FACEBOOK AND TWITTER
BECAUSE.
OTHERS. PIC BECAUSE OTHER SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS WHETHER
INSTAGRAM OR SNAPCHAT.
BUT MORE SIGNIFICANTLY UP
PREDECESSORS
I THERE ARE STILL A IN EXISTENCE
BLOCKS.
A IC'S SOCIAL MEDIA IS WELL AND
THERE'S OFTEN BEEN A QUESTION
OF.
ARE BLOGGERS PAID.
ARE THE YOU KNOW GETTING THEIR.
THEIR THEIR FUNDS AND NOT.
DISCLOSING FLORIDA THEY
ACTUALLY I GOT PAID I CAMPAIGN
OPERATIVES UP OR THE JOURNALISTS
IN THIS IS WHERE THIS.
SPECTRUM.
THE LINES SEEM KIND OF BLURRED
AS YOU GET FROM TWITTER AND
SNAPCHAT I'D TO BLOGS TO THE NEW
YORK TIMES A LOS ANGELES TIMES
DOT COM. A WHO IS THE SOURCE ARE
OR WHO IS THE IMPETUS OFFER AN
EDITORIAL OR AN OPINION PIECE I
THAT THAT THEY INDEED PUBLISH.
WELL I THINK THE AND THE INTENT.
THE INTENT OF THE FOCUS BY THE
BILL WAS THE MAJOR SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES WHERE MUCH OF THE
POLITICAL MONEY NEW POLITICAL
MONEY IS MOVING WITH REGARD TO
S. STATEWIDE BALLOT MEASURES WE
HAD BILLION DOLLARS. SPENT IN
TWENTY TWELVE AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
ON ON STATEWIDE BALLOT MEASURES
I EXPECT MUCH OF THAT MONEY IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
AND BEYOND WILL BE MOVING INTO.
A FACEBOOK AND TWITTER BUT
THOUGH THE WAY THE BILL'S
CRAFTED IT'S PROBABLY APPLICABLE
TO SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM IN
GENERAL BUT YOU RAISE AN
INTERESTING. ISSUE MISTER HARPER
AYE I WANT TO AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD.
WILL MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
CLARITY ON DEFINITIONS AROUND
SOCIAL MEDIA MY GOAL IS BROADLY
APPLICABLE.
AND AND MAKING SURE THAT WERE
CAPTURING.
THAT INFORMATION ON THE MAJOR
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS BUT
WEEKEND I'M FINE TUNE SOME OF
THAT OF LANGUAGE IN TRENTON
ENOUGH YOU WANT TO ADD
ADDITIONAL CHARGES AT A THE
COUPLE WORDS HERE SO THE.
.
THE VERSION IN PRINT HAS A
THRESHOLD THAT WAS TAKEN FROM
THE CONGRESSIONAL ANA STATS
ACTIVE FIFTEEN A ANY SORT REDUCE
PLAQUE FROM THE POSTS ADDS. THAT
HAS FIFTY MILLION OR MORE A
UNIQUE VISITORS PER MONTH.
THAT WAS TAKEN FROM THAT WITH
OUR.
A NEGOTIATIONS WITH THAT
FACEBOOK AND INTERNET
ASSOCIATION WERE TAKEN TO
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD I THINK
CLARIFY THE QUESTION THAT YOU
HAVE.
ONE IS TO REMOVE THE THRESHOLD
SO IT'S NOT ONLY FIFTY MILLION
OR MORE IT WOULD APPLY TO SOME
OF THOSE.
OTHER ONES.
OF THE SPLIT SMALLER THE OLDER
ONES ISSUES AS YOU SAID AT
SECONDLY TO CLARIFY THAT IT'S
IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT BY IT IF A BLOG POST
GOOGLE ADS SECULAR REPLY TO
GOOGLE ADS AS WELL AS AN ONLINE
PLATFORM OUR YAHOO AFTER SOME
OTHER AT. IT'S IT'S THE A
RESPONSIBILITY THE ONLINE
PLATFORM THAT INTERACTS WITH THE
ADVERTISER THE TAKES THEIR
INFORMATION SO AN ADVERTISER
WILL GO TO GOOGLE AT AND SAY.
DO THIS ADDON DO NOT THAT
DESPITE ALL BUT DIFFERENT BLOCKS
IN THE BLOCKS WILL.
GIVE A BANK TO GOOGLE ADS IN
GOOGLE.
WILL GIVE THEM A CUT BASICALLY
BUT NEVER TO THE BLOG OUR
WEBSITE DOESN'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT AT ALL ABOUT THE AT THEY
DON'T INTERACT WITH THE
ADVERTISER SO. THOUGH CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE THAT'S IN THE IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT YOU HAVE NOW.
CLARIFIES THAT SELLS
ADVERTISERS
APPLIES TO THOSE THAT DIRECTLY
THAT PLATFORMS THAT DIRECTLY
INTERACT WITH THE ADVERTISERS
NOT THE. NOT THOSE SMALL BLOGS
THAT THAT AREN'T DEALING WITH
THEM AND DON'T KNOW WHO THEY
ARE.
BUT THAT WOULD ALSO COVER.
OTHER THINGS SO FOR INSTANCE THE
I KNOW FOR A FACT THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN ADVERTISING.
IN HOUSE SO THEY INTERACT
DIRECTLY WITH ADVERTISERS OF THE
NEW YORK TIMES.
TAKES ADDS THEY WOULD HAVE TO
COLLECT THIS INFORMATION AND AND
DISPLAYED IT JUST TO CLARIFY I'M
NOT. TALKING ABOUT THE ADS I'M
TALKING ABOUT CLONE EYES.
CONTENT THAT REALLY MAYBE ACTS
BUT IT'S MATT MASQUERADING AS
CONTENT THAT'S FROM BLOGS THAT'S
FROM AYE MEDIA AND I'M NOT SURE
WHY WE SHOULD GIVE.
QUOTE STANDARD MEDIA A PASS.
WHEN WE'RE TARGETING SOCIAL
MEDIA.
A IF THAT THE VALUABLE POINT
THAT THAT'S BILL IS NOT MEANT TO
ADDRESS THAT IT'S MEANT TO
ADDRESS PAID POLITICAL
ADVERTISING AS DEFINED IN
CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW. AND THE
THE LAST THING I THAT I WANTED
TO RAISE THE ISSUE OF BECAUSE OF
ONE OF THE.
A FOLK CENTER WHO WAS I CAME UP
I'VE ALLUDED TO THIS POINT
THOUGHT ABOUT THE CONCEPT OF
FOREIGN MONEY. AYE AND.
WHETHER THERE IS INDEED A
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE SIX OUTRAGE
AND I WILL POINT OUT.
THAT THE LAST YEAR I INTRODUCED
I AB SEVEN FORTY FOUR WHICH WERE
PREVENT FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS
FOREIGN PRINCIPLES LIVING ABROAD
IN FOREIGN NATIONALS LIVING
INSIDE THE UNITED STATES.
FOR MAKINGA CONTRIBUTION IN
CONNECTION WITH ANY FIT STATE
FEDERAL OR LOCAL CANDIDATE FOR
ELECTION A BALLOT MEASURE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THAT MEASURE. I WAS DEFEATED
HERE IN THE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
ON A PARTY LINE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OR GOVERNMENTS.
GREAT SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND MISTER MULLIN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR.
THE EXCELLENT WORK ON THIS
MIGHT THINK IT A TREND AND HIS
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN FOLKS WHO
ARE REALLY UP PUTTING SOME
MUSCLE ON THE GRASSROOTS BEHIND
THIS EFFORT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OR THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND WITH COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE
AMENDMENTS A TO THIS BILL WHICH
WILL A MOCKUP OF BUT WILL BE
FINALIZED AND THE DAYS TO COME.
GIVEN THE INCREASING ROLE THAT
ADVERTISING ON SOCIAL MEDIA IS
PLAYING IN CAMPAIGNS THIS BILL
WILL BUILD ON LAST YEAR'S
DISCLOSE ACT.
KEEP CALIFORNIA AT THE FOREFRONT
OF CAMPAIGN TRANSPARENCY.
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS TIME TO
FINE TUNE THE LANGUAGE IN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING TAKEN
WE WON'T BE AMENDING THE BILL IN
COMMITTEE TODAY AS ALREADY
MENTIONED. WELL SKIP THIS PART
WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING I
RECOMMEND AND I VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN AYE. BERMAN AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO CALDERON.
LOW. LOW AYE MULLIN AYE AYE
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
SO THAT BILLS OUT BUT WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND MISTER
MULLIN I SEE SOME OTHER AUTHORS
IN THE ROOM SO WE'RE GONNA.
SWITCH AND AND LET SOME OTHER
FOLKS GO SINCE YOU'RE ON THE
COMMITTEE AND YOU HAVE NO CHOICE
BUT TO BE HERE HOLE UNTIL THE
END.
.
OH OKAY.
SO WITHOUT FIRST IS MISTER
QUIRK.
IT'S AN.
WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY FIVE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK BY BANKING
LIKE TO START BY THANKING OUR
SPONSORS.
WITH ARE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF CLERKS AND ELECTION
OFFICIALS.
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE.
AND MANY OTHER ELECTIONS POLICY
EXPERTS.
WHO HAVE ENGAGED IN OUR LONG
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS BILL AND
AMENDMENTS?
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY FIVE WOULD
MOVE CALIFORNIA TOWARDS. RISK
LIMITED AUDITS.
FOR ELECTION RESULTS
CERTIFICATION.
WITH ME TODAY ARE DEAN LOGAN.
OF LA COUNTY.
AND RYAN RONCO OF PLASTER
COUNTY.
WITH THE ARE CLERKS ASSOCIATION
TO FIELD ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK AND AND
LET ME JUST SAY IT'S NICE TO
HEAR YOUR VOICE AGAIN. AND I
HOPE YOU'RE FEELING BETTER.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN ID LOGIN
REGISTER RECORDER COUNTY CLERK
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I'M
HERE TODAY IN MY CAPACITY AS
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS. WE WANNA
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER AYE QUIRK
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL AND WE'RE
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL THIS
FOLLOWS UP ON OUR COMMITMENT TO.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND TO THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR ON THE WORK
THAT YOU DID ON.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FORTY WITH
REGARD TO THE ONE PERCENT MANUAL
COUNT IN CALIFORNIA AND OUR
COMMITMENT TO COME BACK. ON TO
ADVANCE THE IDEA IN THE POLICY
OF DOING RISK LIMITING AUDITS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE AUDITS BASED
STATISTICALLY MEANINGFUL AND
RELEVANT DATA THAT ACTUALLY
AUDITS THE OUTCOME OF ELECTIONS
NOT JUST THE ACCURACY OF THE
EQUIPMENT USED TO TO COUNT THE
BALLOTS.
UP WE HAVE AT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SAID WE'VE SPENT MANY
HOURS IN MEETINGS ON THIS IT'S A
COMPLICATED THE TECHNICAL TOPIC
I AM PLEASED TO SHARE WITH YOU
THAT WE HAVE WORKED. VERY
CLOSELY WITH A DISTINGUISHED.
GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS AND WHO
CARE VERY MUCH ABOUT THIS ISSUE
AND WHO ARE ONLINE THAT WITH THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCURACY VALUES
OF THIS INITIATIVE. AND OTHER
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
READY TO GO ON THIS BILL THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF ITEMS WERE STILL
WORKING ON WE'RE MEETING AGAIN
THIS AFTERNOON THAT I'M
CONFIDENT THAT WE. WILL I'M COME
TOGETHER ON A BILL THAT WE CAN
STAND UNITED ON AND THAT WILL
MOVE CALIFORNIA FORWARD THAT THE
CHALLENGE WITH A BILL LIKE THIS
IS WE WANT TO. ADVANCE THE IDEA
OF RISK LIMITING OUT ITS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HAVE TO DO THAT IN A WAY
THAT ALLOWS COUNTIES THAT ARE
READY TO MOVE FORWARD IN THAT TO
LEAD THE WAY THE ULTIMATE GOAL
OF COURSE IS FOR CALIFORNIA TO
DO THE STATEWIDE AND TO BE ABLE
TO DO. WITH WINNING OUT ITS ON
THE OUTCOMES OF STATEWIDE
CONTEST AND STATEWIDE MEASURES
AYE BUT WE HAVE TO NAVIGATE THE.
A LOCAL MANDATE LANGUAGE AND
THEY THAT THE FISCAL CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT SO THE BILL
BEFORE YOU. ARE ALLOWS COUNTIES
THAT ARE READY TO MOVE FORWARD
IN THAT I WE THINK THAT THAT
WILL BE USEFUL IN AND ACTUALLY
ESTABLISHING BEST PRACTICES AND
POLICIES.
I ALLOWS THE SECRETARY OF STATE
AUTHORIZES SECRETARY OF STATE
TO.
I'M SET COMMON GUIDELINES AROUND
THAT AND A WHAT YOU'LL SEE IN
THE AMENDMENTS COMING FORWARD
ARE VERY CLEAR DEFINITIONS OF
VERY CLEAR STATED THRESHOLD FOR
THE RISK LIMITING AUDITS. AND.
A PATH FORWARD THAT WE THINK
POSITIONS CALIFORNIA TO BE A
LEADER ON THIS AYE IN THE NATION
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO. WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK AND THE
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE AND
OUR STAKEHOLDER PARTNERS SOUND
TO SEE THIS. THEME SILICON.
GOOD MORNING ONCE AGAIN CHAIR IN
MEMBERS.
RYAN RONCO PLACER COUNTY COURT
REPORTER REGISTRAR VOTERS AND.
A CO CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATURE
COMMITTEE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION PARKS IN ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS.
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK AT FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE OF COURSE AND PART
THANK OUR ADVOCACY GROUPS HAVE
BEEN WORKING SO HARD AS DEAN
SAID. ON THIS BILL.
I ONCE AGAIN DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO SAY BECAUSE MY
COLLEAGUE DEAN WE'RE GOING TO
SET IT OFF SO I'M HERE TO HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THEMES RUCKA.
AT GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
TIFFANY MARK ON BEHALF OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AL EXPEDIENCY
PORT.
THANKS DIFFERENT.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AND THE.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OR ANY NEUTRALS.
BUT.
AND CHAIR BERMAN MEMBERS NICOLAS
ITEM WITH CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE. WE WERE CURRENTLY NEUTRON
THE BILL BUT WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORTERS RISK LIMITING AUDITS.
A RISK LIMITING AUDITS ARE
FORMER ACTOR WAYS IN THE ONE
PERCENT MENTAL TALLY TO ENSURE
THE. ACCURACY OF OUR VOTE
COUNTING MACHINES.
AND GENERALLY RESULTING FAR
FEWER BALLOTS BEING COUNTED SO
IT'S ALSO MUCH MORE EFFICIENT
WAY OF DOING SO.
WE ARE CURRENTLY NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL BUT THE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE CONCEPT AND.
CERTAINLY VERY PERCEPTIVE OF
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND FOR WORKING WITH US.
AS WELL SEE CO WE'VE HAD VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS I THINK
WERE REALLY GETTING CLOSE TO
HAVING.
POSITION THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE
ON.
WITH THE AMENDMENT CERTAINLY
COMING FOR WE THINK THERE ARE
VERY MANY POSITIVE ELEMENTS
INCLUDING A PATH TO. HOPEFULLY
EASING IMPLEMENTATION INTO THIS
AS WELL AS SOME REAL STRONG
PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE FOR
EXAMPLE A HIGH LEVEL OF
CONFIDENCE WHEN OUR LEASE
PERFORMED FOR THOSE COUNTIES
THAT OFTEN.
THERE ARE STILL SOME ELEMENTS
THAT WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
THEY WERE WORKING THROUGH THE
AUTHOR AND AND SEE CO. I'D
NOTABLY THE IMAGE TO USE A
BALLOT IMAGES WHICH I'VE.
TO BE DONE WITH THE TO PERFORM
THE OUR LOW USING BALLOT IMAGE
IT'S ONE TALK ABOUT THAT VERY
BRIEFLY. OUR CONCERN IS THAT THE
USE IN OUR LA IS TO VERIFY WITH
A PHYSICAL BALLOT. LEAVE THE
CASTRO RECORD WITH MACHINES ARE
SAYING THE VOTE TALLY IS IF YOU
RELY ON A DIGITAL PERSON TO
VERIFY THAT. IT'S SUSCEPTIBLE TO
POTENTIALLY THE SAME TYPE OF
A POTENTIALLY HACKING THAT WERE
TRYING TO GUARD AGAINST WHEN WE
ACTUALLY GO BACK FISCAL ABOUT.
SUCH AN ISSUE OF CONCERN BUT
IT'S ONE THAT WE'VE HAD
WONDERFUL CONVERSATIONS WITH CCO
ON. AND SO OVERALL I WOULD SAY
I'M VERY POSITIVE THERE WHERE
THIS IS GOING CERTAINLY URGE THE
BILL TO BE. VOTED OUT OF
COMMITTEE SO THAT THIS
CONVERSATION CAN CONTINUE AND
AGAIN THANKS TO THE THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS.
UP LEADERSHIP ON THIS WORKING
WITH US BUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI GOOD MORNING KIM ALEXANDER
WITH A CALIFORNIA VOTER
FOUNDATION AYE WE ARE HOPING TO
SUPPORT THE SPELL IN ITS
CURRENT.
GUIDE STATUS WE COULD NOT AYE WE
WOULD OPPOSE IT BUT WE DO KNOW
THERE. ARE AMENDMENTS IN THE
WORKS AND WE ARE ENGAGING IN
THAT PROCESS I'M AYE ONE ECHO
WHAT NICHOLAS SAID ABOUT. BALLOT
IMAGES THIS IS BEEN AN ONGOING
STRUGGLE IN ELECTION
VERIFICATION IN CALIFORNIA'S
STARTING WITH PAPERLESS
ELECTRONIC VOTING THAT WAS
INTRODUCED AND OUR STATE
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND ONE.
THAT AYE NEGATED AYE THE ABILITY
TO TRULY CONDUCT AN INDEPENDENT
AUDIT WE GOT RID OF THAT WE
REQUIRED A PAPER TRAIL THAT WE
HAD A PASS AND OTHER LAW SAYING
YOU HAVE TO USE THE PAPER TRAIL
TO DO THE AUDIT. ON SO WE HAD TO
KEEP GOING BACK AGAIN AND AGAIN
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ACTUALLY AUDITING. THE BALLOTS
THAT VOTERS CAST THAT VOTERS
TOUCH THAT VOTERS VERIFIED AND
WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT
CONTINUES TO HAPPEN WOULD YOU
WANT CALIFORNIA TO LEAD THE WAY
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE GET IT RIGHT. AYE BECAUSE
RISK LIMITING AUDITS IS A HOME
GROWN IDEA RIGHT HERE ON A
CALIFORNIA AND UC BERKELEY
PROFESSOR AT PHILIP STARK WHO
ORIGINATED IT. I'M WE ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THIS BILL IS
OPTIONAL WE UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGE OF OUR OF OUR ELECTION
MANDATES.
BUT WE WANT TO SEE CALIFORNIA
MAKE A COMMITMENT TO THE CONCEPT
OF RISK LIMITING AUDITS AND WE
SUGGEST THAT ADVOCATES ARE
SUGGESTING. THAT WE COULD DO
THAT BY CONDUCTING A STATEWIDE
RISK LIMITING ANA IN TWENTY
TWENTY ON IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
OF ONE CONTEST IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION THE PRESIDENTIAL OR THE
GOVERNOR'S CONTEST AS A PROOF OF
CONCEPT STATEWIDE SECRETARY
STATE COULD COORDINATE THAT'S.
IT WOULD NOT BE TERRIBLY
EXPENSIVE AYE IT CAN BE QUITE
EFFECTIVE IN IN DEMONSTRATING TO
ALL THE COUNTIES AND ALL THE
VOTERS HO RISK LIMITING AUDITS
WORK AND WHY AMERICAN IDEA. ON
AND WE AND WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THESE ABOUT IMAGES THEY
SAID ON AND WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH.
LA COUNTY AND THE REGISTRARS
AND AUTHORS OFFICE TO WORK OUT
LANGUAGE AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
ALL GET BEHIND AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
NEUTRAL OR OPPOSITION.
.
MA'AM.
HI I'M WITH THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA LEAD
LAWRENCE AND WE DO SUPPORT THIS
BILL IN CONCEPT.
AND WE THINK IT'S GOING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BUT WE AGAIN
WERE WAITING TO. WEAR KAPPA
DETAILS THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
AND WEARING GOOD MORNING MISTER
CORCORAN COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JIM SO PER I'M WITH THE VOTING
RIGHTS TASK FORCE.
A AUTHORED COATED HIS CASKET
ORDERED AND A SENIOR SOFTWARE
CONSULTANT.
ARE VERY BRIEFLY IF.
WE WERE TO CHECK VOTE ON THE
BILL THE DAY WE WOULD OPPOSE.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
FIXED BUT WE ARE HAVING VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE CA CTO. AND WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT THE COMMITTEE PASSED THIS
BILL SO THAT THE CONVERSATIONS
CAN
CONTINUE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RICHARD A CO CHAIR OF THE VOTING
RIGHTS TASK FORCE I WANT TO
THANK A ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CLUB
BILL QUIRK AND.
DEAN LOGAN ON THE CA CEO OF AND.
WE ALSO.
.
ARE NEUTRAL BECAUSE WE NEED
CERTAIN AMENDMENTS
TO PASS BUT WE ARE WORKING WITH
A. THIRTEEN LOGAN'S HERE CO ONE
WEEK. AGAIN I URGE YOU TO PASS
IT AND WE WILL CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AT ON
ANY PART OF THE SPECTRUM.
BRING IT BACK TO COLLEGE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
SAY NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MISTER CORBETT YOU I TO CLOSE. I
WANT TO THANK THE VOTING RIGHTS
TASK FORCE.
FOR INVITING ME TO THEIR.
.
MEETING LAST YEAR. ARE TELLING
ME ABOUT RISK LIMITING AUDITS
AND.
I VERY MUCH HOPE WE CAN GET THE
BELT THAT EVERYONE CAN GET
BEHIND.
IT WOULD GIVE CALIFORNIA
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN HOW TO
VALIDATE ELECTIONS I'D LOVE TO
SEE SOMETHING DONE IN THE
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION BUT
THAT'S.
THAT'S UP TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE FIGURING OUT WHETHER OR
NOT THAT CAN BE DONE.
BUT WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS
THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK HAVING
THE ABILITY TO ON ELECTION
RESULTS IS ESSENTIAL FOR
ENSURING VOTER CONFIDENCE IN OUR
ELECTORAL PROCESS. AND
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT OF
RISK COMMITTING AUDITS THAT
BEING SAID IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES THAT STILL NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED. FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THIS COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION I
WISH THERE THAT MORE OF THOSE
ISSUES HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED
BEFORE WE WERE ASKED TO VOTE ON
THIS BILL BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT ONE.
FOR THE SECRETARY OF STATE
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS AND
ELECTION INTEGRITY AND OTHER
GOOD GOVERNMENT GROUPS SO I WILL
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY WITH THE
AUTHOR'S COMMITMENT WHICH HE HAS
MADE. TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO JUST
CALIFORNIA'S CHALLENGES IN
IMPLEMENTING RISK LIMITING
AUDITS.
AND WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT
THIS BILL WILL RETURN TO THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE FUTURE FOR A
THOROUGH ANALYSIS AND DISCUSSION
WITH THAT COMMITMENT AND
EXPECTATION I RECOMMEND SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. I AGREE. THANK
YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTIONS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE AYE
BERMAN AYE HARPER. HARPER AYE
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE LOW. LOW AYE
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
THE BILL IS OUT AND WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER PORT ANYONE
ELSE.
AND NEXT UP WE HAVE MR CHOW
WITH AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
ARE LIKE TO START OFF BY
ACCEPTING AS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS.
LISTED ON PAGES SEVEN AND EIGHT
HEALTH ANALYSIS.
ARE THE AMENDMENTS ESSENTIALLY
SAY THE FOLLOWING FIRST TOOK
CLARIFIES THAT THE.
PARTICIPATION BY COUNTIES IS.
VOLUNTARY.
TO CLARIFIES THAT INFORMATION
ABOUT THE INDEPENDENT SECURITY
ASSESSMENTS CAN BE SHARE WITH
THE ELECTION OFFICIALS OFF THE
COUNTIES THAT PARTICIPATED IN
THE PILOT. AND THREE ESTABLISH A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE UPON
CONCLUSION OF THE PILOT PROGRAM.
ARE THE BILL ABC TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT WILL ESTABLISH A
VOLUNTARY PILOT PROGRAM FOR
COUNTY ELECTION ARE OFFICIALS TO
HAVE AN INDEPENDENT. ON
CYBERSECURITY ASSESSMENT OF
THEIR ELECTION INFRASTRUCTURE.
ARTS THE STATE HAS A NUMBER OF
CYBERSECURITY RESOURCES AT ITS
DISPOSAL. OF GOVERNOR BROWN'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
B. THIRTY FOUR DASH FIFTEEN
REQUIRED THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
OH YES TO ESTABLISH AND LEAD THE
CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
IMMIGRATION CENTER OR AUSSIE
SICK. WITH A MISSION TO REDUCE
THE LIKELIHOOD AND SEVERITY OF
CYBER INCIDENTS THAT COULD
DAMAGE CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
IT'S A CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
OR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR
COMPUTER NETWORKS IN THE STATE.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY OR CD TEA AND THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
SEE MD OUR PARTNERS IN THE. ALL
CAL SICK.
IN ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THE THREAT
OF CYBER ATTACKS THAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ENACTED EP SIX
SEVENTY.
TO REQUIRE CDT CMT AND ALSO.
YES TO ANNUALLY CONDUCT NO
FEWER THAN THIRTY FIVE I S. ACE
OF STATE AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS OR
OFFICES.
THESE AYE S. A.'S EVALUATE THE
AGENCY ON HOW EFFECTIVELY IT
PROTECTS
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION HEALTH INFORMATION
AND ALSO CONFIDENTIAL FINANCIAL
INFORMATION.
ALONG WITH CONSIDERING HOW THE
AGENCIES PERFORM AT RISK AND
SECURITY MANAGEMENT.
NOW THE SHIFT FROM A SILO OF
THIS JOINT APPROACH TOWARD A
PARTNERSHIP BASED APPROACH. TO
ADDRESS CYBERSECURITY ISSUES ON
THE STATE LEVEL HAS INDEED ARE
MADE A CRITICAL DIFFERENCE IN
BETTER ADDRESSING CYBERSECURITY
CONCERNS IN STATE GOVERNMENT. A.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A FINAL AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT ARE IS
AN EFFORT TO TAKE TO BASICALLY
TO TAKE WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED BY
PULLING OUT STATES.
CYBER SECURITY EXPERTISE AND
APPLIED THE STATE RESOURCES TO
THEIR UTMOST ADVANTAGES ARE IN
CRITICAL AREAS INCLUDING
ELECTIONS.
I DOES SO BY ESTABLISHING A
PILOT PROGRAM TO PERFORM AT A
BEAST SIX SEVENTY LIKE ISA SO
OUR ELECTION INFRASTRUCTURES
PARTICIPATING. COUNTIES ARE
WOULD NOT I RESPECTFULLY A BY
THE WAY ARE ALL OF THE
INFORMATION.
GATHER WILL BE CONFIDENTIAL AND
NOT DISCOVERABLE TO THE PUBLIC
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY OZ FOR
YOUR CAUSE SUPPORTED I BUILT.
AT THE VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION THE SECOND.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ALL BRING A BACK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE OF WHICH I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
LAST MONTH THIS COMMITTEE HELD
A JOINT INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
THETOPIC OF ELECTION
CYBERSECURITY. ONE THE CLEAR
MESSAGES FROM THAT HEARING WAS
THE NEED FOR CONSTANT VIGILANCE
TO THREATS TO OUR ELECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I AGREE WITH THE OFFICES ARE TO
MAKE THE STATE CYBERSECURITY
EXPERTISE AVAILABLE TO COUNTIES
TO HELP SECURE THEIR ELECTION
SYSTEMS. AND I APPRECIATE.
THE AUTHORS WILLINGNESS TO TAKE
THE AMENDMENTS LISTED IN COMMON
NUMBER EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS AND
WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS I'M
RECOMMENDING SUPPORT. AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR.
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
AND WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOST ASTUTE PASSES AMENDED
EMBRY REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN I
BERMAN HIGH HARPER. HARPER AYE
CALDERON.
LOW. LOW AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
SO THAT BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA GO ON
TO MISTER GIPSON A. B. THIRTY
ONE FIFTEEN ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. THANKS FOR ALLOW ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE
FIFTEEN. I'LL BE TAKING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT THIS BILL.
DOES NOT IMPEDE ANY.
ANY IT'S OUR SECURITY PROTOCOLS
AT THE JAILS A. B. ON THIRTY ONE
FIFTEEN SEEKS TO EDUCATE OF
THOSE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED IN COUNTY JAILS.
ABOUT VOTING REGISTRATION AND
VOTERS RIGHTS TO HELP THEM FEEL
MORE CONNECTED TO THEIR
COMMUNITY.
INCREASE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
CALIFORNIA INCARCERATE OVER
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IN HIS JAILS AND MORE THAN HALF
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS HAVE NOT
BEEN CONVICTED OR ARE THEY HAVE
BEEN ON SENTENCE. OF THIS IS A
LARGE COMMUNITY OF THAT HAS
HISTORICALLY.
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM CIVIC
PARTICIPATION DUE TO EITHER MIS
INFORMATION OR LACK OF
INFORMATION MANY. OF WHOM.
ARE BEHIND BARS DO NOT KNOW
THAT THEY CAN REGISTER TO VOTE
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES STATE AND
LOCAL A JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITIES TO ASSIST AND BORDER
REGISTRATION. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE OF AGE AND ARE NOT
SERVING A FELONY SENTENCE THIS
BILL WOULD AND ACT SIMILAR
PROVISIONS FOR DULLED BY
REQUIRING EACH COUNTY JAIL. TO
ALLOW AT LEAST UNDERSCORE AT
LEAST ONE ORGANIZATION TO
PROVIDE VOTER EDUCATION PROGRAMS
IN THE COUNTY JAIL. OF THE
PROGRAM WOULD INCLUDE BUT NOT BE
LIMITED TO INFORMATION ABOUT
VOTERS RIGHTS.
AND VOTER REGISTRATION AND
ASSISTANCE WITH RETURNING.
REGISTRATION CARDS TO THE
ELECTION OFFICIALS. ARE WITH ME
HERE TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE END THAT WAY C. P.. THE
ACLU AND THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ERIC
HARRIS I'M THE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE CONFERENCE OF THEN DOUBLE
ACP THANK YOU FOR HEARING THIS
BILL TODAY.
HOUSE SPEAKER BRIEFLY ABOUT
THREE REASONS WHY THIS BILL IS
SO IMPORTANT.
FIRST ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES WILL
STAY.
.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS THIS OWN
PROGRAM IN PLACE AND IT HAS BEEN
A VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM.
SECOND INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
HAVE THE RIGHT TO REGISTER TO
VOTE BUT MANY DO NOT KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE THESE RIGHTS.
MANY PEOPLE DROUGHT CALIFORNIA
ARE UNDER THE IMPRESSION THAT IF
A PERSON HAS EVER BEEN
INCARCERATED THAT THEY HAVE LOST
THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE.
AB THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN WOULD HELP
CLEAR UP THAT CONFUSION.
FINALLY A. B. THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN
WOULD BE A GREAT STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION FOR CALIFORNIA
TO SHOW INCARCERATED COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
FORGOTTEN ABOUT.
THERE ARE. THERE ARE.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
INCARCERATED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND TENS OF THOUSANDS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN COUNTY
JAILS.
AND MANY MORE WHO HAVE BEEN IN
INCARCERATED AT ONE POINT.
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE AND
CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM ARE MEN OF COLOR AND OF
LOW SOCIO ECONOMIC STATUS.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP THOSE
PEOPLE BECOME A MORE WELCOME
PART OF SOCIETY AND IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON A. B.
THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN.
THE VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING LOSE MARA MIND ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB THIRTY
ONE FIFTEEN.
LEGISLATION THAT REQUIRES EACH
COUNTY JAIL TO ALLOW
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE VOTER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS
THIS BILL TOUCHES ON THE
PASSIONATE PRIOR THE OF THE
LEAK.
VOTING IS A FUNDAMENTAL CITIZEN
RIGHT THAT MUST BE GUARANTEED.
AND EVERY CITIZEN SHOULD BE
PROTECTED AND THEIR RIGHT TO
VOTE.
WE SUPPORT MEASURES THAT WILL
ENSURE GOVERNMENT'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT THIS
RIGHT THE REGULATIONS AND
PROCEDURES THAT IN COURAGE AND.
AN INFORMED AND ACTIVE
ELECTORATE.
IN CALIFORNIA TO BE ELIGIBLE TO
VOTE ONE MUST BE A U. S. CITIZEN
OF IS A RESIDENT OF THE STATE
AND EIGHTEEN YEARS OR OLDER ON
ELECTION DAY. MANY WHO ARE IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
MEET THESE REQUIREMENTS AND ARE
ELIGIBLE TO REGISTER AND VOTE.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER A GIPSON HEAD
CALIFORNIAN CAR STATE EIGHTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE CURRENTLY IN ITS
JAILS AND MORE THAN HALF. OF THE
PEOPLE HAVE NOT BEEN CONVICTED
OR REMAIN ON SENTENCE.
DUE TO EITHER MISINFORMATION OR
LACK OF INFORMATION MANY WHO ARE
BEHIND BARS DO NOT KNOW THAT
THEY CAN REGISTER TO VOTE OR
THERE ARE SYSTEMATIC BARRIERS IN
PLACE. THAT DO NOT ALLOW THESE
PEOPLE TO EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT.
WE BELIEVE VOTER EDUCATION IS
CRUCIAL FOR ALL AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND RUSHED AND
RESIDENTS. AND IT IS WHY WE SO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL I
THINK YOU THINK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
ESTHER LIN DIRECTOR OF THE ACLU
SOCAL GELS PROJECT I'M UNDER
CONDITIONS OF CONFINEMENT IN THE
LA COUNTY JAILS WHICH IS THE
LARGEST JAIL SYSTEM IN THE
COUNTRY WITH SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO ARE BEHIND BARS.
FORTY EIGHT PERCENT OF THEM ARE
PREACH HELL EIGHTY PERCENT ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO.
WHEN IT COMES TO RIGHT TO
REGISTER TO VOTE INCARCERATED
MANY EXCLUDED FROM THE PROCESS
TO TO LACK OF INFORMATION OR
NONE AT ALL. LIMITED ACCESS TO
VOTING MATERIALS AND
INCONSISTENT AND BIG VOTING
POLICIES AND PRACTICES THAT VARY
FROM COUNTY BY COUNTY ALMOST
SIXTY THREE PERCENT INCARCERATED
COMMUNITIES ELIGIBLE TO VOTE
WHICH MEANS AN LA COUNTY JAILS
ALONE. THAT'S MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THE IS SERVICE A CALIFORNIA
UNLOCK THE VOTE PROJECT WITH THE
LA SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT THE
REGISTRAR'S OFFICE AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS. HAVE REGISTERED OVER A
THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH A SLIGHT
MAJORITY BEING FIRST TIME
REGISTRANTS EDUCATION BEING A
VITAL COMPONENT TO INCREASING
ENGAGEMENT.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE
FIFTEEN.
I CAN BRING PEOPLE FROM THE
JAILS HERE BUT I WILL SHARE
THREE STORIES.
FROM OUR UNLOCK THE VOTE
CAMPAIGN.
EGGMAN CENTRAL JAIL WE FINISH
COMPLETING A YOUNG LATINAS MAN'S
FIRST TIME REGISTRATION PACKET.
WHEN HE RETURNED TO HIS HOUSING
MODUL HE WAS GREETED BY SOUNDS
OF CHEERS AND APPLAUSE MS DORM
MATES FOR TAKING THE FIRST STEP
IN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
AT THE WOMEN'S FACILITY WE WERE
GREETED BY AUDIBLE YESES WHEN WE
TOLD THEM WHY WE WERE THERE.
AFTER WE COMPLETED ONE WOMAN'S
REGISTRATION.
SHE HUGGED THE VOTING MATERIALS
CLOSER CHEST
WHAT THE BIG TOOTHLESS GRIN SHE
SAID FINALLY
VOTE.
LASTLY.
AFTER I GAVE AN ELDERLY MAN THE
UNLOCK THE VOTE BROCHURE I
STRETCHED OUT MY HAND TO SHAKE.
HE INSTINCTIVELY BONTA THREATS
TOWARDS ME TO SHOW ME HIS WRIST
BAND.
THIS IS SOMETHING THEY DO
FREQUENTLY IN THE JAILS FISH FOR
COUNT FOR MEDICATION TO VERIFY
THAT THEIR NAME MATCHES OUR
BOOKING NUMBER.
I TOLD MY DIDN'T SEE HIS WRIST
BAND I JUST WANTED TO SHAKE HIS
HAND.
HE WAS SHOCKED AND HE SAID OH
PEOPLE DON'T WANNA SHAKER HANDS
AND HERE
IT'S NO CONTACT FOR US.
AFTER WE SHOOK HE LOOKED AT ME I
SAID WITH PASTOR THINK.
THESE ARE NOT UNIQUE EXPERIENCES
ARE A RARE OCCURRENCES THIS IS
WHAT WE SEE AND HEAR EVERY DAY
WHEN WE'RE INSIDE THE JAIL STERN
VOTER EDUCATION AND
REGISTRATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
IT'S LIKE PUTTING LEGISLATIVE
ATTORNEY ON BEHALF OF MALTA
MEXICAN AMERICAN LEGAL DEFENSE
AND EDUCATIONAL FUND.
THANK YOU.
HI TIFFANI PULLEYBLANK NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE TEMPERATURE VOTING RIGHTS
TASK FORCE CA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GUIDE JIM SO PER AUTHOR OF
CANADA'S CAST AT WORK THE
FOUNDING PRINCIPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY IS NO TAXATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION.
IF YOU CAN VOTE.
YOU NOT BEING REPRESENTED THANK
YOU AYE AYE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
JEFF MOCKUP BEHALF OF THE
SECRETARY STATE ALEX VIDEO WE
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT GETTING A
SUPPORT LETTER AND. WHERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH?
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY NEUTRALS ARE TRAINERS SAYING
NINE BRING IT BACK TO COLLEGE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THEY HAVE.
BUT YOU'RE HARPER.
YOU CAN HELP ME UNDERSTAND ON.
IN TERMS OF BUT THE REQUIREMENT
FOR THE SAKE GET OUT THE VOTE
ORGANIZATIONS IN.
IN JAILS AND. AND IF I CAN GET
IT IS IT'S THE SPECIFIC TO JAILS
AND AND NOT PRESENCE THAT IS
CORRECT.
AND.
.
WHAT ABOUT THE SITUATION OF
CANDIDATES FOR PUBLIC OFFICE ARE
INCLUDED IN THESE GET OUT THE
VOTE ORGANIZATION SO THEY
GUARANTEED? ACCESS.
WITH THE CANDIDATES OWE A
CANDIDATE FOR LEGISLATURE CANDY
FOR LOCAL OFFICE VOTE ORGAN IS
A.
VOTER REGISTRATION
I CLOSE CORRECT AND EDUCATE AND
EDUCATION THINK YES.
MATTER PREDICTIVE.
NOR.
SO LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS ARE
PUT OUT NONPARTISAN MATERIALS.
MISS EDUCATION AND ALSO VOTER
REGISTRATION.
YES BUT.
CAN A CANDIDATE BE A PART OF.
THESE GROUPS THEY'RE GOING INTO
THE JAIL TO CANDIDATES PART OF
THE ORGANIZATION IT'S GOING AND
THAT'S PART OF THE APPROVED.
PROCESS BY THE SHERIFF'S THEY
CAN GO IN AND ACT ON THE
UMBRELLA. OF THE ORGANIZATION
THAT IS GOING PROVIDING VOTER
EDUCATION AND VOTER INFORMATION.
IN ALBERTA CANADA EXCLUSIVELY
NO.
AND DON IF FIVE WE HAVE BEEN
HERE THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
EACH COUNTY JAIL ALLOW AT LEAST
ONE ORGANIZATION. I COULD WE
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE COMPETING TO
BE THE FIRST ONE OR AND OTHERS.
COMPETING ORGANIZATIONS ARE
EXCLUDED.
OF WHAT WE'RE WE'RE ASKING FOR
AT LEAST ONE ORGANIZATION AND
SO.
WE DON'T WANNA KEEP WE DON'T
HAVE A TO BE A PARTISAN SO WAS
NONPARTISAN THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION WHAT THETHAT THAT
ACTUALLY GETS TO THE HEART OF
THE QUESTION IS.
YOU KNOW IS POINTED OUT THAT.
THAT SOME OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS COULD OUT POLITICS
THAT MAYBE LEANING RIDER
LAUGHTER CENTER OR BUT MAYBE
THEY ARE.
I INTERESTED IN A PARTICULAR
POLICY ISSUE.
OR A POLITICAL ISSUE AYE AND IS
THIS IS POTENTIALLY A SITUATION
WHICHOTHERS WITH A DIFFERENT.
FLOSS BE A DIFFERENT OBJECTIVE
IN THE ARE EXCLUDED SIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF COURSE IN THE
BILL AS ASK FOR AT LEAST ONE
CERTAINLY THE FACILITY CAN
APPROVE MORE THAN ONE. WE'RE
ASKING FOR AT LEAST ONE.
SO THERE'S ORGANIZATION THAT.
THAT WANTS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION CERTAINLY.
WITH APPROVAL IN THE PROTOCOLS
BEING MAD AND AND.
IT HERE TO BUY THE ACTUAL
FACILITY ABSOLUTELY.
APPRECIATE CLARIFICATION THANK
YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE.
MISTER GIBSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S A LOT OF CONFUSION
ABOUT STATE LAWS GOVERNING
VOTING RIGHTS AMONG PEOPLE WHO
HAVE CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS.
SO PROVIDING ACCURATE
INFORMATION AND VOTER EDUCATION
IS ESSENTIAL TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYBODY KNOWS ABOUT THEIR
RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW.
I DON'T THINK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE AN AMENDMENT
TO ADDRESS THE SECURITY CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED AYE AND
WITHOUT AMENDMENT I'M
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PROCESS
AMENDED AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN AYE AYE BERMAN AYE
HARPER.
HARPER KNOW CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE KNOW. LOW AYE
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE YES NO
WEBER.
WEBER I IS A THAT BILLS THAT
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VERY MUCH.
AND THANK YOU AND NEXT UP WE
HAVE IS MR
ROW HERE WE HAVE MISTER CHOI.
I WAS ROSE HERE WHERE.
HOPE I DON'T SEE THEIR SORRY
SIR.
WE HAVE MISTER BOROUGH WITH.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY ONE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
BUT IN THE CALIFORNIA VOTING
RIGHTS ACT PERVERTED PRESERVING
A FLOATING FORMAT WHICH RESULTS
IN POLARIZED VOTING IS A
VIOLATION OF THE LAW.
NOTHING IN AB TWENTY TO THIRTY
ONE WILL CHANGE THAT IN THIS
BILLS INTENT IS NOT TO UNDERMINE
THE ENFORCEMENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT. AS
A PROTECT AGAINST POLARIZED
VOTING IN CALIFORNIA HOWEVER THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT AS
A SIMPLE ONE SIZE FITS ALL
REMEDY. EXPRESSLY IDENTIFIES
DISTRICT ELECTIONS IS ONE OF THE
CLEAR AVAILABLE REMEDIES
AND WHILE ADOPTING A BY DISTRICT
ELECTED ORDINANCE AS A LAWFULLY
CRAFTED ELECTION DISTRICT IS A
CONVENIENT RESPONSE. IT'S NOT
ALWAYS THE SOLUTION THAT SOLVES
A PARTICULAR ISSUE PRESENT
WITHIN A CITY EACH CITY IS
DIFFERENT WITH DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS.
DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHY IN DIFFERENT
LOCAL OBJECTIVES
CURRENT LAW FOR TO CITY A SMALL
WINDOW OF TIME TO CONSIDER
NECESSARY CHANGES TO THE
ELECTION SYSTEM AND RECENTLY.
THIS COMMITTEE PASS AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY THREE TO STAND THAT
TIME FRAME.
BUT WITHOUT FIRST ADDRESSING THE
BASIS FOR WHICH THE VIOLATION
OCCURS OR THE OPTIONS AVAILABLE
PUBLIC AGENCIES WILL SIMPLY.
TRANSITION TO BUY DISTRICT
ELECTION PROCESS.
AS IS IS PRESS WE IDENTIFIED AND
IS THE MOST COMMON REACTION BY A
CITY.
A FAIR AND EQUAL REPRESENTATION
REPRESENTATION IS NOT ALWAYS
ENSURE BY DISTRICT ELECTION
PROCESS.
RATHER THAN ATTEMPTING TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUE UNDER THE
THREAT OF LITIGATION.
THROUGH THE STANDARDS IN THIS
BILL THEN IN SOME WAY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS NEED OPTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT THE THOUGHTFUL AND
EFFECTIVE APPROACHES TAKE XIN.
TOWARD AN AFFAIR IDENTIFY THE
NECESSARY ALTERNATIVE REMEDIES
TO A VOTING RIGHTS ACT
VIOLATION.
AB TWENTY TO THIRTY ONE SEEKS TO
PROVIDE ACTUAL AND BENEFICIAL
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL HELP RESOLVE
THE POLARIZATION FACTORS PRESENT
WITHIN COMMUNITIES.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SCOTT SAYS
BILL. AND.
WITH ME TODAY IS COREY WILLIAMS
ARE FROM TOWNS AND PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
MISSION VIEJO THERE'S THE BILL
SPONSORED. THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
MOTION AND A SECOND MAN THINK
HE'LL PUBLIC AGENCIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HAVE FACED RECENT
LAWSUITS ALLEGING THAT THE OUT
LARGE.
ELECTION PROCESS VIOLATES THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT BY
DILUTING THE MINORITY VOTES
ALMOST ALL OF THESE PUBLIC
AGENCIES HAVE SETTLE CLAIMS OUT
OF THE COURT BY VOLUNTARILY
SHIFTING TO DISTRICT BASED
ELECTIONS.
THE CITY OF MISSION VIEJO WAS
RECENTLY FACED WITH THIS LAWSUIT
ASSERTING THAT THE CITY'S OUT
LARGE ELECTORAL SYSTEM DILUTES
THE ABILITY OF LATINOS TO ELECT
CANDIDATES OF THEIR CHOICE. ARTS
OTHERWISE INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME
OF THE CITY COUNCIL ELECTIONS.
A PROFESSIONAL REVIEW OF ALL
VOTING PATTERNS DATING BACK TO
TWENTY TEN AND FOX SHOWS
EVIDENCE OF RACIALLY POLARIZED
VOTING IN MISSION VIEJO. HOWEVER
IT ALSO SHOWS THAT DISTRICT
ELECTION MAPPING WOULD NOT BE AN
APPROPRIATE REMEDY TO RESPOND TO
THE RACIALLY POLARIZED VOTING.
ADOPTING OF BY DISTRICT ELECTION
ORDINANCE THAT PUTS INTO PLACE
LAWFULLY CRAFTED ELECTION
DISTRICTS IS A CONVENIENT
RESPONSE BUT NOT ALWAYS THE
SOLUTION THAT ACTUALLY SOLVES
RACIALLY POLARIZED VOTING. AND
ENSURES THAT ALL MEMBERS OF THE
CITY INCLUDING MINORITY GROUPS
ARE FAIRLY REPRESENTED.
THE OPPOSITION WILL STATE THAT
THIS BILL IS COUNTER TO
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO CONVERT TO DISTRICTS BASED
ELECTIONS. THIS IS NOT TRAIL WE
FULLY SUPPORT DISTRICT ELECTIONS
IF IT WILL SOLVE THE ISSUE OF
DILUTING THE MINORITY VOTES
HOWEVER AGAIN DISTRICT ELECTIONS
ARE NOT ALWAYS A REAL SOLUTION
TO THIS VERY REAL PROBLEM.
EACH CITY IS DIFFERENT WITH
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS DIFFERENT
GEOGRAPHY AND DIFFERENT
DEMOGRAPHICS THERE'S NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM.
AB TWENTY TO THIRTY ONE WILL
DEVELOP A MORE STRINGENT
STANDARD FOR VOTING RIGHTS ACT
VIOLATIONS TO ASSURE A FAIR AND
UNBIASED ELECTION AND TO ENSURE
THAT MINORITY GROUPS ARE
APPROPRIATELY REPRESENTED. AND
SAID OF ATTEMPTING TO THAT
RESOLVE THE THREAT OF LITIGATION
WITH THE REACTIVE HASTY SOLUTION
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
MINORITY GROUPS ARE REPRESENTED
BY ENSURING THAT A THOUGHTFUL
EFFECTIVE APPROACHES TAKEN TO
RESOLVE THIS ISSUE.
AB TWENTY TO THIRTY ONE DOES
IMPOSE A HIGHER STANDARD TO
ENSURE THAT SOLUTIONS WILL
PROVIDE ACTUAL AND BENEFICIAL
RESULTS THAT WILL HELP RESOLVE
THE POLARIZATION FACTORS PRESENT
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE OXFORD YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
PLAYING GRAM LEGISLATIVE
ATTORNEY FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA GOOD MORNING.
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE SPELL
BECAUSE OF SNIFFING CAN CHANGES
IN THE LEGAL STANDARDS AND
REMEDIES AVAILABLE UNDER THE CVR
A. AND BECAUSE OF THE CHILLING
EFFECT THE CHANGE IN THE
ATTORNEY FEES PROVISION COULD
HAVE ON CVR A PLAINTIFFS BRING
IN THEIR CASES. WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL IS COUNTER TO THE INTENT OF
THE CVR A WHICH WAS ENACTED TO
ALLOW. CHALLENGES TO
DISCRIMINATORY VOTING AND
RACIALLY POLARIZED VOTING.
DAVID THIS BILL MAKES
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES IN THE LEGAL
STANDARDS ON FOR PREVAILING ON
CBR.
CBR A CLAIMS IT REQUIRES A
PLAINTIFF TO. DEMONSTRATE ALL
THREE OF THE LEGAL PRECONDITIONS
WHEN THE CVR I CURRENTLY ONLY
REQUIRES TO.
THIS CHANGES A CORE PRINCIPLE OF
THE CVR A WHICH WAS TO ALLOW THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER AT LARGE
ELECTIONS ABRIDGED OR DILUTED
THE RIGHTS OF VOTERS. FROM THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER THEY WERE
GEOGRAPHICALLY CONCENTRATED.
IT ALSO CONTAINS A PROBLEMATIC
SHIFT IN THE REMEDIES UNDER THE
SEA VERY NOW ONLY THE COURT CAN
IMPOSE REMEDIES THIS ALLOWS THE
VIOLIN TEEN VIOLATED ENTITY. TO
IMPLEMENT ITS OWN REMEDIES AND
THE BILL IS UNCLEAR WHETHER THE
VIOLIN AND TO DATE COULD DO SO
OVER THE OBJECTIONS OF
PLAINTIFFS THAT PREVAILED OR THE
COURT. MAY ALSO THINK THAT THE
SHIFT IN THE ATTORNEY'S FEES
COULD CHILL PLAINTIFFS ABILITY
TO BRING THESE CASES ON THAT
RECEIVE ER. AND FORCE THEM TO
MOVE TO HAVING TO BRING CLAIMS
UNDER THE MORE CUMBERSOME AND
BURDENSOME AND COSTLY FEDERAL
VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
AND THIS BILL IS COUNTER TO THE
BIPARTISAN LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS
OVER THE PAST YEARS TO BOTH
EXPAND.
WHAT JURISDICTIONS CAN MOVED OUT
DISTRICT ELECTIONS AND TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR THEM TO IMPLEMENT
AND DISTRICT ELECTIONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NO VOTE ON
THE SPELL?
THANK YOU. COURTING MY NAME'S
DOOR ROSE I AM DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WITH LEGAL MATTERS VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY WE ARE YEAR INDEED
TO OPPOSE.
AB TWO TO THREE ONE. THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT WAS
INTENDED TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF
RACIALLY POLARIZED VOTING IN
VOTE DILUTION. OF.
TO PROVIDE COMMUNITIES WITH THE
ABILITY TO READ TOOK TO ELECT
REPRESENTATIVES THAT WOULD
REALLY REFLECT THE NEEDS OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES TO EXPAND
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY THAT'S
THE POINT OF IT.
THIS BILL UNDERMINES A OF THE
INTENTION OF THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
IT CURRENTLY TO MAKE OUT A CVR A
CASE A A POLITICALLY COAST
COHESIVE MINORITY IS GOT TO BE
ABLE TO SHOW. THAT THERE IS
RACIALLY POLARIZED VOTING AMONG
THE MAJORITY COMMUNITY RIGHT. AB
TWO TO THREE ONE A SUPER CHARGES
THAT BURDEN OF PROOF IT
SUPERCHARGES THE BURDEN OF PROOF
IT REQUIRES THE PLAINTIFFS SHOW
AS A THRESHOLD MATTER.
THAT THERE IS A GEOGRAPHIC
COMPACTNESS OR THEY COULD BE
GEOGRAPHIC COMPACTNESS AMONG
THE.
MINORITY A DISTRICT
THE CBR A WAS SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED IN CONTRAST WITH
FEDERAL LAW.
RIGHT WE AT WHICH WORDS YOU
WOULD OF A.
THIS BILL TRIES TO PULL US BACK
INTO IN CONTRAST WITH FEDERAL
LAW TO ENSURE THAT GEOGRAPHICAL
COMPACTNESS IS NOT A PART OF
MAKING A THRESHOLD CASE IT'S NOT
A BAR.
TO BRINGING A A CVR A CASE IT IS
A A COMPONENT IN DETERMINING
WHETHER OR NOT A A REMEDY IS
APPROPRIATE. THAT'S WHERE IT
BELONGS
BUT NOT AS A BAR TO BRING THE
CASE UP IN THE INITIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE.
.
THE BILL ALSO ESTABLISHES THIS
THIS SCHEME WHEREBY PLAINTIFFS
SEEKING INJUNCTIVE NOT MONETARY
RELIEF
WOULD.
.
AND YOU ARE UNABLE TO MEET THIS
NEW THIS.
BURDENSOME BURDEN OF PROOF.
WOULD HAVE TO PAY GOVERNMENT
ATTORNEY FEES
CLEARLY THAT.
SHIFTING OF ATTORNEY FEES IT IS
DESIGNED TO HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT
ON PLAINTIFFS WHO MIGHT
OTHERWISE LEGITIMATELY. NEED TO
BRING A CD ARE A CASE TO ADDRESS
A THE DISCRIMINATORY IMPACT OF
LOCAL ELECTIONS.
LEAGUE SUPPORTS UP PLANS TO
PROTECT AGAINST DILUTING THE
VOTING STRENGTH OF LINGUISTIC
AND RACIAL MINORITIES WE OPPOSE.
ARE AB TWO TO THREE ONE
STRONGLY.
BECAUSE OF BY IMPOSING THESE
DRACONIAN HURDLES TO SEE VERY
LITIGATION BY CREATING THESE
UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY
BURDENSOME PROSPECTIVE
PLAINTIFFS.
THE BILL'S GOING TO IMPEDE
REALLY CRITICAL WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE TO ACHIEVE
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL HEARING CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
JANET SITE BUT THE LEGISLATIVE
STAFF ATTORNEY ON BEHALF OF
MULTI OF MEXICAN AMERICAN LEGAL
DEFENSE AND EDUCATIONAL FUND
ALSO IN STRONG OPPOSITION FOR
THE REASONS CITED. I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL TO NOTE THAT.
THIS BILL DOES HAVE SEVERAL
CHILLING EFFECT SMALL DEFENSE
ONE OF ONE OF A HANDFUL OF OF
ORGANIZATIONS HERE. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT BRING SEE VERY
CLAIMS AND WE ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT.
HAVE ABOUT WHAT EFFECT THIS
WILL HAVE A MONTH FOR
COMMUNITIES OF FOR PLAINTIFFS
WHO UP HAPPEN RIGHT WHO HAVE
BEEN. PRETTY MUCH LEFT OUT OF
THE VOTING SYSTEM BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THAT. UMPS SOME
JURISDICTIONS CONTINUE TO I'M
EITHER USE THAT LARGE ELECTIONS
OR CONTINUE TO DILUTE ON.
MINORITY OUT VOTING THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SINGING NINE AGAIN
VERY BACK TO COLLEGE FROM
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
OBERNOLTE OF ADVICE YOUR HARPER.
NO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I A
QUESTION FOR THE OPPOSITION SO
I'D DO MY DUTY CO YOU. DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT.
A PLAINTIFF SHOULD BE REQUIRED
TO PROVE THAT A SWITCHED TO BUY
DISTRICT ELECTIONS WOULD BE
BETTER THE FOR A PROTECTED
CLASS.
BEFORE FORCING AS CITY TO MOVE
TO DISTRICT ELECTIONS.
I THINK THE LEGAL STANDARDS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN PLACE OF THE
CVR A ADEQUATELY PROTECT BOTH
INTERESTS AND PUTT.
THE PROPER BURDEN ON THE
PLAINTIFFS IN MAKING THEIR CASE
TO PREVAIL.
ALRIGHT ARM I I HAVE TO
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THAT
AND TO THE EVIDENCE IS ON MY
SIDE BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK ACROSS
THE STATE. WE'RE SEEING AN
EXPLOSION OF WHAT I WOULD CALL
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS AGAINST
CITIES AND OTHER GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCIES. THAT ARE ATTEMPTING TO
FORCE TO MOVE THEM TO AT LARGE
ELECTIONS FROM MY DISTRICT
ELECTIONS I'VE SOME PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS.
THAT I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH THE
COMMITTEE I THAT'S THE CITY THAT
I LIVE IN THE CITY OF BIG BEAR
LAKE. IDEAS.
HAS KIND OF A PARTICULAR PROBLEM
WE HAVE BY EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE
HOUSING STOCK UP THERE IS SECOND
HOMES BECAUSE WERE VACATION
DESTINATION SO THE FULL TIME
POPULATION THE VOTING POPULATION
OF THE
IT IS ACTUALLY QUITE SMALL.
ABOUT SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE SO IF
YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT A CITY
COUNCIL ELECTION LOOKS LIKE IN
THAT CITY.
IF YOU HAVE A FOUR THOUSAND OF
THOSE PEOPLE REGISTERED TO VOTE
AND YOU HAVE A AND A
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION MAYBE.
THIRTY OR FORTY PERCENT VOTER
TURNOUT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
MAYBE FIFTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE
THAT ARE VOTING IN ELECTIONS
WHICH IS INCREDIBLY SMALL.
THEY RECENTLY GOT A LETTER.
FROM A PREDATORY LAW FIRM AND
ARE RATHER THAN BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO FIGHT IT AND
HAVEN'T LOOKED AT PRESIDENT
THEY.
CONCLUDED THAT NO CITY THEIR
SIZE COULD WIN. A CHALLENGE.
UNDER THE CVR A.
AND REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT
A PROTECTED CLASSES RIGHTS WERE
BEING VIOLATED AND YOU KNOW
HAVING LIVED IN THAT CITY I I'D
SHARE THEIR OPINION THAT.
THERE'S NO VIOLATION OF A
PROTECTED. CLASS BUT.
BUT THEY THEY CONCLUDED THEY
COULDN'T FIGHT IT IT NEVER
FINANCIAL RESOURCES DO SO
THEY'RE GOING TO DISTRICT
pTHAT SO FIFTEEN OTHER PEOPLE
VOTE NOW THEY HAVE FIVE
DISTRICTS SO THREE HUNDRED
PEOPLE.
ARE VOTING IN EACH DISTRICT AND
IT REQUIRES FIFTY PERCENT TO GET
ELECTED A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PEOPLE ARE ELECTING A CITY
COUNCILMAN.
THAT IS RIDICULOUS.
OUR IT LEADS TO A COUPLE OF
UNIQUE PROBLEMS FIRST OF ALL
EVERYONE IN THE CITY NOW FEELS
DISENFRANCHISED BECAUSE WHEREAS
BEFORE THEY HAD A SAY. IN THE
COMPOSITION OF THE ENTIRE
COUNCIL NOW THEY ONLY HAVE A SAY
IN THE COMPOSITION OF ONE.
COUNCIL SEAT
SO THAT'S ONE PROBLEM FOR LARGER
PROBLEM IS THAT WE HAVE PROBLEMS
EVEN FINING PEOPLE. OF THOSE
HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE WHO WHO
WANT TO SERVE ON CITY COUNCIL
YOU KNOW IT'S A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE ARE WILLING
TO PUT THEMSELVES OUT THERE AND.
SERVE IN PUBLIC OFFICE AND SO.
WE'RE GETTING TO THE POINT
WHERE WE HAVE TO TALK PEOPLE
INTO RUNNING.
I WHICH IS COMPLETELY COUNTER TO
A FREE DEMOCRACY AND WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
MULTIPLE PEOPLE INSTEAD OF
HAVING. A.
A OF ELECTION BY ACCLAMATION
WHERE PEOPLE DON'T HAVE A CHOICE
BECAUSE THERE'S ONE NAME ON THE
BALLOT. SO THEY'VE JUST A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PROBLEMS THAT ARE ARE
BEING CAUSED BY THIS AND IT'S
NOT JUST IN THE CITY I LIVE IN
BUT IT'S ACROSS CALIFORNIA THAT
THIS PROBLEM IS OCCURRING AND.
THAT I THINK THAT WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE BEAR RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THIS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT A
PROBLEM EXISTS.
AND THAT'S IS NOT TAKE AWAY FROM
THE GOOD WORK THE TO SEE OVER
THE ARE A DOES IT'S NOT TO SAY
THAT ALL CITIES ARE LIKE.
MY CITY.
WHERE H. SWITCH TO BUY DISTRICT
ELECTIONS WOULDN'T BENEFIT A
PROTECTED CLASS BUT NOT ALL
CITIES ARE LIKE THAT AND I THINK
THAT IT'S A REASONABLE THING? TO
BE ABLE TO TO HAVE TO REQUIRE A
PLAINTIFF WHO BRINGS A CHALLENGE
UNDER THE CITY ARE A TO PROVE
THAT A SWITCH TO BUY DISTRICT
ELECTIONS WOULD ACTUALLY BE
BETTER FOR THE PEOPLE WE'RE
TRYING TO PROTECT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S UNREASONABLE AT ALL. SO I
I'D LIKE TO ENCOURAGE.
I THIS THIS BODY THE LEGISLATURE
IN THIS COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE BECAUSE WE
ARE DOING A DISSERVICE TO
GOVERNMENTS INTO CITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA BY FAILING
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
YOU'RE MUCH VICE ARBOR AND THEN.
MISTER CALDERON THANK YOU I
SHARE THE CONCERNS ARE THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM A BIG BEAR LAKE
HAS.
I AND ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE PUT OVER
THE BARREL BY THIS PROCESS.
I IT SEEMS CLEAR TO ME AFTER
HEARING THE COMMENTS THAT UP
PART OF THE.
THE OPPOSITION'S MOTIVE IS TO
BE ABLE TO KEEP THE PIPELINES OF
CASH FLOWING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
TO THE.
THEIR TREASURIES TO ATTORNEYS
TO LAWYERS AYE WHO HAVE THIS
WEEK SIGNIFICANT ADVANTAGE WITH
BEING ABLE TO I ASK FOR THESE
ATTORNEYS FEES ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU HAVE SMALLER JURISDICTIONS.
OUT WHICH FEEL THE OBLIGATION TO
PAY OUT BECAUSE IT'S SO RISKY
FOR THEM TO ACTUALLY GO IN THE
OTHER DIRECTION.
I FOR THE PURPOSES OF SLICING UP
SMALL COMMUNITIES THERE ALREADY
SMALL TO BEGIN WITH.
IN DIVIDING OUR CITIES ARE I
THINK THAT THIS BILL PROVIDES AN
OUTSTANDING REMEDY FOR THIS
SITUATION AND I THINK THAT.
WHAT THIS IS DEVOLVED INTO IS
ABSOLUTELY DEPLORABLE?
THE VERY MUCH MISTER CALDERON.
WELL FIRST MISSOURI THANK YOU
FOR THE CONVERSATION I ALWAYS
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION
TO TALK ABOUT THIS AND I I HAVE
NO DOUBT. THAT WHAT YOU'RE
OFFERING.
IS IS SERVICING THE NEEDS OF
YOUR DISTRICT IN YOUR COMMUNITY
IN THE CITY OF MISSION VIEJO
SUBSEQUENTLY I. I WENT TO IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL.
IN THE CITY A MISSION VIEJO HA.
YEAH BUT I ALSO HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF EXPERIENCE.
WITH THIS I REPRESENT A
COMMUNITY ASSEMBLY SEPT SEVENTY
PERCENT LATINO AT MY DISTRICT.
ARE AND SO YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE
CITY OF LA MIRADA PRICKLY IN A
PREDOMINATELY LATINO NOW WHEN
THE TINO SITS ON THE CITY
COUNCIL THEY JUST MOVED DISTRICT
ELECTIONS.
IN THE CITY OF ANAHEIM DID THIS
WAS NOT IN MY DISTRICT THE CITY
OF ANAHEIM DID THIS HAD NO
LATINO ON THE. ARE ON THE THE.
.
THE CITY COUNCIL OTHER AS A EN.
IT AND I THINK THE BIGGEST CASE
A AND AND AND AND THE STRONGEST
EXAMPLE THAT I HAVE IS MY CITY
THE CITY THAT I LIVE IN IS THE
CITY OF WHITTIER. WHICH WE OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS A CITY WITH.
THE TWO CITIES WITHIN ONE AYE
BECAUSE THEY'RE VERY DIFFERENT.
ARE.
DIFFERENCES VERY BIG
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN ARE AT THIS
CITY OUT ONE SIDE VERSUS THE
OTHER YOU HAVE ONE SIDE IS
REALLY NICE REALLY IF ONE WERE
ON THE HILLS. WELL LOT OF
INVESTMENTS ARE MADE A LOT OF.
A LOT OF THE CITY.
HAS BEEN TAKING CARE OF WHERE
ON THE SIDE CITY WHERE I LIVE
ARE IT'S BEEN A VERY MUCH
IGNORED AND THERE'S A LACK OF
RESOURCES AND LACK OF. OUR
INVESTMENT ON THAT SIDE OF
WHITTIER AND AND I THINK.
A THE ISSUE IS IS THAT.
ALL OF THE.
COUNCIL MEMBERS OF THE TIME WERE
LIVING OBVIOUSLY IN THE VERY
NICE PART.
OF WHAT YOU'RE NOT LIVING ON THE
PART. WHERE I LIVE?
I AND AND SO WOULD HERE THE CITY
OF WHAT YOU'RE VOLUNTARILY WENT
TO DISTRICT ELECTIONS WITH AN AT
LARGE MAYOR.
AND AND NOW THERE ARE.
THREE LATINOS
THAT OUR ON THE CITY COUNCIL THE
DISTRICT IN WHICH I LIVE NOW
THERE IS A LOT INVESTMENT
THEY'RE MAKING INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS IN IMPROVEMENTS ARE
DOING HOUSING PROJECT. ARE
WITHIN THAT SIDE IN THAT PART.
OF OF MY TOWN A OUT OF MY SIGHT
OF WHITTIER.
AND AND JUST IN TERMS OF
TURNOUT BECAUSE WE LOOK WE
LOOKED AT.
.
I THINK LOCAL ELECTION JUST IN
GENERAL THERE'S ALWAYS VERY LOW
TURNOUT ESPECIALLY IN THE CITY
OF WATER BECAUSE IT'S AN OFF.
CYCLE ELECTION IT'S AN APRIL
IT'S NOT A JUNE OR NOVEMBER AND
SO THE TURNOUT IS USUALLY VERY
LEVEL WE BROKEN UP BY THE
DISTRICTS WHAT THEY AT FIGURE
OUT THE DISTRICTS. AND THE TURN
ON THE DISTRICT WHERE I LIVE HAD
MORE THAN DOUBLED.
WITH WITH THE.
WITH THAT ONE WE WANTED DISTRICT
ELECTIONS AND ELECTED AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S NOT ONLY LGBT
BUT ALL IS ALSO A LATINO THAT
HAS BEEN ABLE TO ADVOCATE. AND
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK WITH TO
REOPEN A COURTHOUSE TO TO GET
THESE INVESTMENTS INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS HOUSING PROJECTS.
AYE AND SO IT REALLY HAS IS DONE
A LOT TO HELP OUT.
.
ME PERSONALLY IN TERMS OF WHERE
I LIVE IN MY DISTRICT AND SO
I'VE SEEN THE IMPACT I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF VALUE IN THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
AND YOU KNOW.
I'M JUST CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF THIS BILL WOULD HAVE
ON AND I NO DOUBT THINK THAT YOU
KNOW AGAIN THE YOU ARE
ADVOCATING FOR YOUR COMMUNITY I
JUST FEEL LIKE. THIS BILL MOVING
FORWARD WOULD WOULD BE HARMFUL
TO MIKE.
AT THIS TIME BUT I'D I DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK THE WORK
THAT YOU DON.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON.
.
I AM A COMMENTS THAT ARE GONNA
LET. ASK YOU TO CLOSE THE AS
OPPOSED ALLEN ONLY DO IT.
BUT THE CALIFORNIA VOTING
RIGHTS ACT THAT HAS HAD A
TRANSFORMATIVE EFFECT ON THE WAY
THE LOCAL OFFICIALS ARE ELECTING
CALIFORNIA AND WHILE I AYE
DIFFERENT KNOW. THAT THE AUTHOR
IS TRYING TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED BY
CITY IN HIS DISTRICT.
I DO FEAR THAT THIS BILL WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY WEAKEN THE TOOLS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO CHALLENGE
AT LARGE ELECTION.
THAT UNDERMINE VOTING RIGHTS.
BUT WHILE AT THE SAME TIME I'D
I'D.
DON'T THINK THIS BILL IS IS
PERFECT I ALSO DON'T THINK THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT IS
PERFECT
A AND I DO THINK THAT THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT IS
BEING ABUSED.
A BY LAWYERS.
WHO WHO HAVEN'T NECESSARILY
DONE THE PROPER RESEARCH INTO
CERTAIN JURISDICTIONS AND
WHETHER OR NOT MOVING TO ADD
DISTRICT ELECTIONS IS THE IS THE
RIGHT SOLUTION?
FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES NOW I
DON'T THINK IT'S HELPFUL OR
ACCURATE TO IMPUGN THE MOTIVES
OF THE DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
HERE TODAY.
BY IT BUT I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THOSE STAKEHOLDERS
ASIDE TO IDENTIFY.
IMPROVEMENTS THAT CAN BE MADE
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED.
I I DON'T THINK THAT THIS IS
THE RIGHT SOLUTION TODAY.
BY I'D I DO THINK THAT THERE
ARE IMPROVEMENTS THAT THAT I'D
LIKE TO DISCUSS A AND LIKE TO
GET. THE DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
IMPORT ON.
BECAUSE.
NOW WE CAN'T JUST
KEEP ON OPPOSING EVERY EVERY
SOLUTION AND NOT INTRODUCE SOME
SOLUTIONS
OF OUR OWN SO ALEC FOR TO HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS IN IN.
BOAT.
WILL RECOMMEND IN THE POST
POSITION ON ON YOUR BILL TODAY.
AND I WITHOUT GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE WELL EARNED
FIRST MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
PUBLICLY THANK YOU.
THIS BILL CAME UP TO SHORTS
WEEKS AGO BUT WITH THE SITUATION
IN MISSION VIEJO YOU PROVIDED ME
WITH THE COURTESY. OF GETTING IT
ON THIS AGENDA ABOUT SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THAT
ADDITIONALLY THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT. INITIALLY PROVIDED
SOME ABOUT SOME OBSTACLES WE
REMOVE THE FISCAL LABELED THAT
GOT US PASSING GUIDELINES I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU PUBLICLY YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR. FOR HELPING THE
UP.
IF THIS BILL ON THE AGENDA AND
HOPEFULLY WE STARTED A
CONVERSATION HERE.
.
AS WAS SAID BY.
COREY WITH TOWNS A PUBLIC
AFFAIRS THE MISSION VIEJO
EXAMPLE DID FIND SOME
IRREGULARITIES BUT WAS SPREAD
OUT THROUGH THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES GOING TO DISTRICTS
WOULDN'T SOLVE THAT ELECTION.
AND SO AS WE WORK THIS
LEGISLATION.
.
WE FOUND IN THE LAW THAT THERE'S
THESE ALTERNATIVE REMEDIES THAT
AREN'T REALLY DEFINE SO REALLY
MY INTENT HERE IS TO GET US OUT
OF THE LITIGATION. BOTH SIDES.
THE OPPONENT SAID IT WAS VERY
COSTLY BURDEN ON PLAINTIFFS AND
THEY WERE WORRIED ABOUT
ATTORNEYS FEES AND GOVERNMENT
RATES.
WELL IT'S VERY BURDENSOME ON THE
TAXPAYER TO TO GO THROUGH THESE
COSTLY ABOUT A LITIGATIONS. IF
THE PARTIES CAN COME TOGETHER
AND GOING TO MEDIATION SETTING
AND COME UP WITH THESE
ALTERNATIVE REMEDIES THAT WOULD
SATISFY PROBLEM SO WHAT MY AND
HOPEFULLY A START OF A
CONVERSATION. THAT WE CAN GET
OUT OF THIS STALEMATE LITIGATION
AND FOR EXAMPLE LIKE MISSION
VIEJO IF DISTRICT ELECTIONS WORK
THE ANSWER.
MAYBE THE PARTIES CAN GET
TOGETHER AND SEE WHAT THESE
ALTERNATIVE REMEDIES WHICH ARE
DIVINE LAW BUT COULD BE SO
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE MOTIVATION
FOR THIS BILL. AND.
YOU KNOW I RESPECT CLASH DRIVE
VOTE BUT HOPEFULLY WE STARTED A
CONVERSATION I KNOW IT'S LATE IN
THE SESSION BUT MAYBE WE CAN
TAKE THIS UP NEXT YEAR JUST. AND
FIX SOME OF THE ISSUES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY BERMAN NO. BERMAN NOW
HARPER.
HARPER AYE CALDERON.
CALDERON NO LOW.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE WEBER.
SO THAT'S TWO TWO AND WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND THAT'S ON CALL PUT IT AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER THANK
YOU.
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO.
MISTER SHORE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY FIFTY
ONE.
ONE OF YOUR.
IN THE MORNING CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS SAW OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT MY
BA L. AB OUT TWENTY FIFTY WANT.
AB TWENTY UP FIFTY ONE OR THE
ALLOWED THE CANDIDATE TO SPEAK
MINE.
FOR EACH CANDIDATE THE FOR
ELECTIVE OFFICE SITE IN A LOCAL
AGENCY STATEWIDE OFF HIS SELF
FOR A STATE THE SENATE THE WALL
ASSEMBLY.
TO BE YEAH CHANGED DURING THE.
APPEAL RIO THE FULL FILING
NOMINATION.
TO ILLUSTRATE THE HIGH IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN A CANDIDATE
THE FOR STATE ASSEMBLY IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO CALLED ACCIDENTALLY STATED
THAT THAT HE WAS DUMB MAYO OFF
AS CITY. UP WITHIN THE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
.
A HE WAS SO RUNNING FOR ON HIS
STUCK CANDIDATES STATEMENT.
THIS STATEMENT THE WASHED OUT
INCORRECT NOW FOR THE CANDIDATE.
OUT WAS THE MAYOR PRO TEM NOT
FAMILIAR.
NO ATTENDED IT THE STATE THE
THAT THAT IT WAS SUB TYPE A
TIGHT BALL AND THE PLAYING. OF
STATE ELECTION LAW FOR NOT
ALLOWING HIM TO CORRECT THE
ERROR.
EVEN BEFORE THE FILING DEADLINE.
CURRENT LAW.
ALLOWS.
OF FOR STATEMENT TO BE
WITHDRAWN.
BUT DOES NOT CHANGE.
DURING VIA PEORIA DUFFEL
FIGHTING NOMINATION PAPERS
AND UNTIL LATER FIVE P. M. OFTEN
NEXT WORKING DAY AFTER THE CLOSE
OF THE NOMINATION PERIOD.
SO DE JA CONVENTIONAL LA OUT
RESPONSE TO RESUME.
PUFFING AND SIDE EXPO EXPOSURE
BY THE UP CRASS
OR ARE POLITICAL ATAKA BY THE
OPPOSITION.
HE REASONABLE OR ARE MILLER
BROWN DAHLE ON.
CASES OF ACCIDENTAL OR MISSION
ONE MISTAKE I WOULD BE OUT TO
ALLOW FOR SELF CORRECTION.
HOW ON ARE MOSTLY ACCURATE THAT
STATEMENT CANDIDATE THE
STATEMENTS
WHEN AN ARROW WAS OF FOUND THAT
BEFORE THE ARE? DEADLINE.
I'M WILLING TO. LIMIT.
JUSTIN ONE TIME ARE CORRECTION
TO PREVENT DATA MAY BE ABUSED.
US SOMEONE RAISE THAT QUESTION.
OUR AND THEN ALSO ATON.
AS YOU KNOW THE DEADLINE HAS
PASSED ABOUT THE WE CAN MAKE GOD
THIS ONE TO BE EFFECTIVE OUT
FROM.
THE E..
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
NOT TO AFFECT THIS YEAR'S
SELECTION.
ABOUT WHY THE CANDIDATES ARE
CANNOT CHALLENGES ELECTION
VICTORY. THROUGH THE COURT
PROCESS SO.
FIGHTING OF FILING A LAWSUIT IS
SAW AN EXPENSIVE ENDEAVOR AS YOU
KNOW OF FOLK CANDIDATES ENDORSE
IT TAKES TIME.
FOR THIS REASON A. B. TWENTY
FIFTY ONE OFFER SUCH A MORE
RECENT EMPLOYER REMEDY.
COLLEAGUES
BY ENACTING AB.
TWENTY FIFTY ONE WE PROVIDE A
COMMON SENSE OF SOLUTION. SO
ISSUES SO FUN NECESSARILY
ARISING FROM AROUND THE
CANDIDATES STATEMENTS.
I RESPECT MEDIA ESCORIAL I'VE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OR CONCERN.
GOOD MORNING ONCE AGAIN RIGHT
RUN GO WITH THE PLASTIC COUNTY
THAT COURT REPORTER ELECTIONS
OFFICE AND CA CEO.
WE ARE NOT.
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
WHERE I WORKING WITH DOCTOR
CHOICE OFFICE WE'RE VERY
THANKFUL FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY.
TO. WORK ON THIS HE'S MADE SOME
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS THAT.
ADDRESSING OUR CONCERNS BUT IN
YOUR ANALYSIS YOU'LL SEE THAT WE
STILL HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS BILL AND WE JUST WANTED OF
KNOWLEDGE THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL BONUSES IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NINE BRING
ABOUT BECAUSE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
MISTER OBERNOLTE AND MISTER
THEM MUCH SHARPER.
A THINK MISTER CHAIR TO THANK
YOU FOR BIG BRING THE BILL
FORWARD UP HAPPY TO SPORTED
TODAY I DO HAVE ONE CONCERN THAT
I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU TO LOOK AT
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
A AND THAT IS THAT WE CERTAINLY
WOULD NOT WANT TO ENABLE
POLITICAL GAMESMANSHIP.
WITH THIS CHANGE TO THE TO
ELECTION LAW SO.
FOR EXAMPLE IF TWO CANDIDATES
WERE TRYING TO ONE UP EACH OTHER
EACH SUCCESSIVELY AMENDING THEIR
BOOK.
THEIR STATEMENTS THAT WOULD NOT
BE YOU KNOW GOOD THINGS
CORRECTING ERRONEOUS INFORMATION
IS IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
WE SHOULD PERMIT SO.
OKAY TO.
.
REMEDY THAT CONCERN PLENTY A.
THE END OF OF FILING PERIOD.
NO ONE CAN SEE.
EACH OTHER SO STATEMENT.
SO YOU WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
CHANGE.
BASED UPON YOUR OPPONENTS
STATEMENT.
SO IT'LL BE YOURSELF CORRECTION.
A.
SOMEHOW. THAT CANDIDATES SAID
THE MAYOR.
TO.
YEAH GIVE HIM A BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT THE AND MAYOR PRO TEM
MAYOR AS SIZE AND NOT A TYPO BUT
THE.
IF FOR.
HE OR SHE HAS CORRECTED THAT
DURING THAT PERIOD THE WHY WOULD
JULIUS ARE NOW BUT THEY'RE NOT
THE CORRECTION. THAT IS A VERY
LOGICAL TO ME.
CHUCK WELL YOU CERTAINLY HAVE MY
SUPPORT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WEREN'T ENABLING
THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR.
THANK YOU.
BUT HOWEVER.
THANK YOU JUST UP ALONG A
SIMILAR LINE I APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENT THAT THAT YOU TOOK
BECAUSE I THINK IT PREVENTS SAID
THAT SITUATION BECAUSE WHAT I. I
DIDN'T WANT TO SEE.
WAYS FOR THEY STATEMENTS TO BE
REVEALED PEOPLE MODIFY THEM IT
WOULD BE MORE OF A REPORT ALL.
I'D BEEN A STATEMENT OF
QUALIFICATIONS WHICH IS WHAT
THE.
ACTUALLY ARE IN SO WELL WITH
THAT THOSE AMENDMENTS AYE AND
DIE I WOULD ENCOURAGE TO KEEP.
WORKING WITH THE RED SHARP
VOTERS BY TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
AYE CAPTAIN WITH WITH THEIR WORK
FLOW. AYE BECAUSE THAT IS YOU
AND I KNOW AT THE ORANGE COUNTY
REGISTRAR VOTERS OUT WITH SO
MANY JURISDICTIONS.
UNDER THE.
THE COUNTY AYE IT'S CERTAINLY A
CROWDED ATMOSPHERE THOSE THE
LAST A COUPLE OF DECADES AND
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE APPROACHING
AYE TOWARDS THE A VERY AND.
BUT WITH THAT DEBT I'LL MAKE
THE A MOTION NOW FOR YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU.
I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND ANY
ADDITIONAL.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
BUT MANY ASKED WE ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AND
WHILE I APPRECIATE. A THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
GAME PLAYING ISSUES PREVIOUSLY
REYES.
I I STILL BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL IS UNNECESSARY.
THAT THE BALLOT STATEMENT THAT
WE MAKE IS.
THAT WAS PROBABLY THE MOST
CLOSELY SCRUTINIZED TWO HUNDRED
WORDS THAT I EVER WROTE.
IN MY LIFE.
AND. YOU KNOW WHAT A CANDIDATE
SHOULD DO IS IS WAIT TILL THE
END WAIT TILL THEY'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH IT MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE.
DONE ALL THE EDITS NECESSARY
BEFORE SUBMITTING IT BUT EVEN IN
THIS INSTANCE AT YOU AS YOU SAID
WE WE DON'T ALLOW OTHER PEOPLE
TO SEE IT BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO ALLOW GAMESMANSHIP. NON THAT
MEANS THAT IF SOMEBODY.
BY ACCIDENTALLY CALLS
THEMSELVES THE MAYOR.
AMATEUR HOW SOMEBODY BY
ACCIDENTALLY DOES THAT.
THAT STILL WON'T BE REVEALED
UNTIL AFTER THE FILING DEADLINE
AND AND SO AND THEN THERE ARE
CERTAIN REMEDIES THAT CAN BE
MADE TO ADDRESS THAT AND AND I
FEAR THAT THIS WOULD CREATE A
LOT OF WORK.
FOR OUR REGISTRARS ESPECIALLY AT
AT THE TIME WHEN THEY'RE THE
MOST BUSY BECAUSE OF US DIG
CANDIDATES AND AND BY HUMAN
NATURE WE.
ARE DEADLINE DRIVEN AND NOBODY
FALLS THEIR PAPERWORK UNTIL THE
VERY END ANYHOW AND SO.
BECAUSE OF THOSE CONCERNS IT
THAT ARE OUT AND AND OTHERS THAT
ARE ONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
I'M UNABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN. BERMAN NO HARPER. HARPER
AYE CALDERON.
LOW.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE WEBER.
WEBER NOW.
SO THAT BILL IS ON CALL THE TO
TO VOTE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE ARE
DID NOT BELONG CALL.
.
AND NEXT UP.
IS.
NOW ABOUT.
DOCTOR WEBER.
LET'S DO IT AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY TWO. ITEM NUMBER FOUR
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY HAVE THE PLEASURE
PRESENTING AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
TWO WHICH MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO FACILITATE THE NEW
METHOD OF COUNTING STATE
PRISONERS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS.
SINCE THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ACTIVITIES THAT OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND IT TAKES.
A NEW DISTRICT LINES FOR LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE BASED ON CENSUS COUNTS.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE HAVE A
SYSTEM WHERE A CENSUS WHERE
EVERYONE IS COUNT IT
APPROPRIATELY.
THAT INCLUDES A HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND INCARCERATED PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
PRIOR TO TWENTY ELEVEN STATE
PRISONERS WERE COUNTED AS
RESIDING AT THE STATE FACILITY
WHERE THEY WERE HELD INFLATING
THE POPULATION OF COUNTIES WHERE
THEY MIGHT WHERE THERE MIGHT BE
FEWER PEOPLE OTHERWISE.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN GOVERNOR BROWN
SIGNED AB TWO FOUR TWENTY WHICH
REQUIRED ALL STATE INMATES TO BE
COUNTED AT THEIR LAST KNOWN
PLACE OF RESIDENCE INSTEAD OF AT
THE CD. SEE OUR FACILITY STATED
STARTING WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS.
THAT ALONE SHOULD THE PRISONERS
WILL BE COUNTED AS AS PART OF
THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES WHICH
BETTER REPRESENT THEM.
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGESIT TO FACILITATE THE
TWENTY TWENTY HAS CENSUS DATA
TRANSFER FROM CDC ARE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION. THAT
DATA INCLUDES AN ANONYMOUS
IDENTIFIER RACE ETHNICITY AND
LAST KNOWN PLACE OF RESIDENCE
WHICH WILL HELP THE COMMISSION
DRAW THE NEW LINES INTO A FOOT
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THIS BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION WITH ME TODAY IS
KAREN MCDONALD THE DIRECTOR OF
THE STATEWIDE DATABASE AND
ELECTION ADMINISTRATION.
ADMINISTRATION RESEARCH CENTER
AT UC BERKELEY.
GOOD MORNING. CHAIR BERMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHEN MS
CURRENT MCDONALD'S I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATEWIDE
DATABASE ON A JOB THAT I FELT
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY FOUR.
THE STATE WERE DATABASES THE
REDISTRICTING DATABASE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO SERVE AS A LIAISON TO THE
CENSUS REDISTRICTING AND VOTING
RIGHTS STATE OFFICE.
STATEWIDE DATABASE JUST TO GIVE
YOU A QUICK OVERVIEW IS OUR
LONGITUDINAL DATA BASE AT BILL
STATE ASSETS OVER TIME SO THAT
POPULATION PARTICIPATION AND
VOTING TRENDS CAN BE ASSESSED.
WE COLLECT DATA FROM EACH COUNTY
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS FOR EACH
STATEWIDE ELECTION WE PROCESS
THE DATA AND THEN WE PROVIDED
THROUGH. A WEEK PROVIDED
PUBLICLY THROUGH OUR WEBSITE.
AT THE END OF EACH DECADE WE
MARCH ALL OF OUR PREVIOUS
COLLECTED DATA SETS TO THE NEW
CENSUS DATA.
AND TO THIS TO THE NEW CENSUS
GEOGRAPHY TO BUILD A
REDISTRICTING DATA SET FOR USE
ELSE. WHO IS INTERESTED IN USING
THE STATE ARE?
YES THEY WERE DATABASES A
TRANSPARENT PUBLIC AND
NONPARTISAN PROJECT ARE LOCATED
ON THE UC BERKELEY CAMPUS.
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT FOR
NUMBER OF REASONS INCLUDING THAT
IT STREAMLINED STATE OUR
TRANSFERS SO ABOUT WORK ON
INTEGRATING THE DATA INTO THE
REDISTRICTING. DATA SAID CAN ARE
BEGIN IN A TIMELY FASHION
AND THAT WILL ALLOW FOR
POTENTIAL PROBLEMS TO BE WORKED
OUT IN ADVANCE AND THEN
DOCUMENTATION TO BE CREATED FOR
THE NEW DATA SET. SO THAT THE
NEW CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION WHICH OF COURSE WILL
BE INCOMING AT THAT PARTICULAR
ERA POINT IN TIME WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DECIDE WHETHER OR
NOT TO USE THE AGES THE ADJUSTED
DATA.
SECOND IT CLARIFIES THE DATE ON
WHICH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF OUR CORRECTIONS AND WE URBAN.
REHABILITATION ARM
HAVE TO GIVE US THE DATA SO ARM.
THE DATA HAVE TO BE CURRENT ON
THE SAME DATE ON WHICH THE
CENSUS COLLECTS A TWENTY TWENTY
DOESN'T SUIT AT DECENNIAL CENSUS
WHICH IS ON APRIL ONE TWENTY TWO
AND. TWENTY WHICH OF COURSE
ISN'T STATE.
IT ALSO ALLOWS THE CDC ARE TO
SHARE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
INMATE POPULATIONS RACE AND
ETHNICITY.
SO THAT THE SENSE DATA CAN BE
ADJUSTED ON BOTH ENDS ON THE END
WHERE THE FACILITY IS AND THEN
ALSO WHERE THE PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO BE ALLOCATED.
ARE IN THE SENSE BLOCK WHERE THE
FACILITIES LOCATED AND THEN ON
THE CENSUS BLOCK ON THE OTHER
END.
THERE ARE SOME PROBLEMS THAT
WOULD ARISE IF THIS BILL DID NOT
PASS ARM ONE IT WOULD CREATE
SOME SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS IN
MAKING THE ADJUSTMENTS THAT AB
FOR TWENTY THE POLICY THAT.
PASSED IN TWENTY TEN HAD
ENVISIONED A ONE WE WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO ADJUST THE RACE AND
ETHNICITY DATA WITHOUT CD SEE
ARE GIVING IT TO US CLEARLY.
AND ARE ALSO THE DATA STATE THE
DATA SAID RECEIVED FROM CDC ARE
MAY NOT BE FROM THE SAME DATE AS
A CENSUS DATA BECAUSE THEY HAVE
A CONSTANTLY FLUCTUATING
POPULATION THIS WOULD CREATE
DATA PROBLEMS.
AND FINALLY THE STREAMLINED AT
DATA TRANSFER WILL GIVE US SOME
CERTAINTY FOUR WHEN THE DATA
WILL ARRIVE SO THAT WE CAN
PREPARE FOR IT. SO TO SUMMARIZE
THIS IS REALLY A BILL ABOUT
TECHNICAL DETAILS REGARDING THE
DATA AND THE DAN DATA TRANSFER.
AND ARE IT WILL REALLY MAKE THIS
BILL ARM BETTER IMPLEMENTABLE
AND MORE EFFICIENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY THIS
NOTICES IN SUPPORT.
THOSE MODOC MINE ON BEHALF OF
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THINK
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I BRING ABOUT HER
COLLEAGUES FROM QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS
BUT ROBERT. VERY MUCH MISSED.
THIS BILL HELPS I IMPLEMENT AB
FOR TWENTY.
WHICH ASKS THE CITIZENS
REDISTRICT MISSION TO ACCOUNT
PRISONERS OUT WHERE THEY USED TO
LIVE UP BUT NOT WHERE THEY LIVE
NOW.
USING PUBLIC RESOURCES
IT WOULD ALSO APPLY TO PRISONERS
ON DEATH ROW A IS WELL AS THOSE
SERVING LIFE SENTENCES
BUT WHY WOULD WE WANT TO COUNT
PRISONERS ON DEATH ROW AND THOSE
SERVING LIFE SENTENCES.
I.
INSTEAD COUNTING THEM PLACES
WHERE THEY'RE NEVER GOING TO
RETURN TO.
WELL THE ASSUMPTION IS THAT THEY
MAY NEVER RETURNED BUT SOMETIMES
THEY DO RETURN NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO. OTHER STILL HAVE TO BE
REPRESENTED I MEAN PEOPLE WHO
INCARCERATED OFTENTIMES STILL
PAY TAXES.
AND.
AND AND AND OWN A PROPERTY AND
A HOST OF OTHER THINGS IN
CALIFORNIA. ARE AND THEY NEED TO
BE COUNTED SO IT'S A MATTER OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY GIVING
IT ACRID COUNT.
OF THE ASSUMPTION IS THAT MAYBE
A FEW PEOPLE ON DEATH ROW BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIANS CENSUS COUNTS
EVERYONE WHETHER THEY'RE CITIZEN
IN OUT. THE PURPOSE IS TO COUNT
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I AM TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PLACE
IS THEY COME FROM WHAT THE
PLACES WHERE THEY HAVE BEEN
IDENTITY AS THEY HAVE THE
GREATEST AMOUNT OF
REPRESENTATION FOR THEM.
BEAR MANY WHO OUR WORK MAY BE
ON LIFE SENTENCING WHO ACTUALLY
GET OUT I MEAN WE DON'T KNOW. A
AND SO IT IS IMPORTANT WE DO AND
WE KNOW THE PEOPLE ON DEATH ROW
STAY THERE FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
IT IS NOT JUST A QUICK THING
THAT THEY GO IN AND OUT. OF IT
BUT IT THE CENSUS COUNTS EVERY
PERSON WHO IS IN CALIFORNIA AND
EVERY STATE.
I AGREE WITH YOU ON MAKING SURE
THAT EVERYONE'S COUNTED BUT IT
USE A VERY SPECIFIC EXAMPLE TO
ASK THE QUESTION MANSON FAMILY
MEMBER PATRICIA KRENWINKEL. IS
SERVING A LIFE SENTENCE FOR
MURDER.
AND HAS BEEN LIVING AT THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR WOMEN
IN CHINO IN SAM BERTINO COUNTY
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE.
PRIOR TO HER ARREST IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE SHE LIVED IN
CHATSWORTH.
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AT THE SPAHN
RANCH.
WHY SHOULD SHE BE COUNTED?
AS LIVING IN LOS ANGELES
RATHER THAN CHINO.
THE QUESTION OF PEOPLE BEING
REPRESENTED IF THEY'RE LIVING IN
CORCORAN IF THEY'RE LIVING IN
SAN QUENTIN THAT THEY'RE LIVING
IN FOLSOM.
OR IF YOU'RE LIVING IN CHINO
SHOULDN'T THEY BE COUNTED WHERE
THEY LIVE. THIS IS ANOTHER BILL
THAT WE DID NOT THAT IS NOT THIS
BILL BASICALLY THIS IS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL THAT
WAS PASSED WHAT IN TWENTY TEN.
PUT ELEVEN.
THAT WAS PASSED AT THAT TIME
AND SO WE'RE IMPLEMENTING THAT
BILL.
WERE NOT BASICALLY. ARGUING
WHETHER WHERE THEY SHOULD BE
COUNTED THAT WAS ALREADY DECIDED
IN THAT PARTICULAR BILL THIS
HELPS TO IMPLEMENT IT. WHAT
SPECIFIC TO THIS BILL BUT IT
DOES REQUIRE THE CDC ARE TO
REPORT INMATE CENSUS DATA TO THE
LEGISLATURE?
BUT THE LEGISLATURE IS YOU KNOW
IS NO LONGER INVOLVED IN DRAWING
POLITICAL DISTRICT BOUNDARIES SO
WHY SHOULD THIS LEGISLATION
REQUIRE THAT INFORMATION BE
GIVEN TO THE STATE LEGISLATURE
WILL HAVE HER ANSWER FOURTH.
YEAH THE LEGISLATURE'S ACTUALLY
STILL RESPONSIBLE FOR BUILDING
THEIR REDISTRICTING DATA SET. SO
THAT IS BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR THE DATA TO BE MORE
STREAMLINED GIVEN TO US SO THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY DO THAT.
VISIT ON THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFICATION THANK YOU MUCH
TROUBLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I NEED A SO THAT ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COLLEAGUES.
I.
I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
.
WE JUST CLOSED OUT WEBER OUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THIS IS A TECHNICAL BILL
BUILDING ON A OF A BILL THAT'S
TEN YEARS OLD IN TERMS OF JUST
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE KEPT
ACCURATELY IMPLEMENT. OF THE
REDISTRICTING THAT WELL CURRENT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ONE THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL AND FOR
WORKING WITH OUR COMMITTEE STAFF
TO ENSURE THAT PREVIOUSLY
ENACTED LEGISLATION.
CAN BE CARRIED OUT AS ORIGINALLY
INTENDED.
AS WE APPROACH THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS AND THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
REDISTRICTING PROCESS.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE ENSURE
THAT THE CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION HAS THE INFORMATION
IT NEEDS TO COUNT PRISONERS AT
THEIR LAST KNOWN PLACE OF
RESIDENCE FOR REDISTRICTING
PURPOSES IF THE COMMISSION
DECIDES TO DO SO.
SO I RECOMMEND SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BERMAN AYE
BERMAN AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO CALDERON.
LOW LEVEL AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO WEBER AYE
WEBER AYE. SO.
THAT BILLS ON CALL ON A THREE
TWO VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I AM GOING JUST MOVING DOWN THE
LIST I AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY TWO
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. MR LOW.
SECOND.
VERY MUCH RICHARD MEMBERS THIS
IS. SIMPLY TAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM JAIL LIKE
OUR JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT WITH
RESPECT TO A COUNTY ELECTIONS
AND GIVES RECOMMENDATIONS WITH
THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO COME
UP WITH.
SOME GUIDELINES WITH RESPECT TO
GLOBAL HEIRESS RESPECT WE ASK
FOR AB. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SING NINE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NINE THAT
MOVING IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SEEING
NINE WE HAVE A MOTION. AND A
SECOND MITCHELL I THINK THIS
BILL IS A REASONABLE RESPONSE TO
THE FINDINGS RELEASED IN THE
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT LAST YEAR
AND SOARING THERE ARE BEST
PRACTICES AVAILABLE TO HELP
MITIGATE AREAS IN FUTURE
ELECTIONS WILL HELP INCREASE
VOTERS CONFIDENCE. IN OUR
ELECTORAL PROCESS I KNOW THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO TRY TO ADDRESS
FEEDBACK FROM THE COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS IN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND I
APPRECIATE THOSE EFFORTS AND
WANT TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO
CONTINUE. AND I RECOMMEND
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE.
BERMAN AYE HARPER. HARPER AYE
CALDERON. LOW. LOW AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE SO THAT BILL IS OUT
AND WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MOVING DOWN THE ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN ARE MISTER
HARPER ANY OF YOUR THREE BILLS
IN ANY ORDER THAT YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT
.
NO GO AHEAD PRESENTED FOLLOWER
GREAT THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
HERE PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE THIS
BILL WOULD RESTORE THE CITIZENS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO A SPEEDY
RECALL AND REMOVE TO REMOVE
ELECTED OFFICIALS. ACCUSE THE
MISCONDUCT AND REPLACE THEM WITH
A SUCCESSOR FOR THE TERM OF
THEIR OFFICE
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
SPECIFICALLY PROVIDES THAT ONCE
THE REQUISITE NUMBER SIGNATURES
ON A RECALL PETITION HAS BEEN
PRESENTED CERTIFIED. THE RECALL
ELECTION MUST BE HELD WITHIN
SIXTY TO EIGHTY DAYS YET
RECENTLY SOME CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS FILED TO RECALL
SENATOR WHO REPRESENT HIM AND
THE RULES WERE CHANGED WHILE THE
PROCESS WAS UNDERWAY.
CITIZEN ACTION WAS THE BIRDS
TOOK THE MAJORITY PARTY COULD
SAVE ONE OF THEIR OWN.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTEEN.
THIS LAW NEW LAW ADDED COSTLY
AND LENGTHY DELAYS TO THE RECALL
PROCESS AND OBSTRUCTED THE WILL
OF THE PEOPLE.
PREVIOUSLY EXISTING LAW GAVE
VOTERS WHO SIGNED THE RECALL
PETITIONS UP TO THIRTY DAYS TO
WITHDRAW THEIR SIGNATURES.
IF THERE WERE ENOUGH SIGNATURES
TO QUALIFY THE RECALL THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCES.
WOULD HAVE TO ISSUE THE COST OF
THE ESTIMATE RECALL ELECTION.
AFTER THAT PART WAS COMPLETE THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WOULD HELP THERE ARE
THIRTY DAYS FOR REVIEW AND
COMMENT ON THE ESTIMATED COST OF
ELECTION. SINCE NINETEEN
THIRTEEN THERE'VE BEEN ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR RECALL
ATTEMPTS LAUNCHED AGAINST STATE
OFFICIALS BUT THE RECALL OF
STATE SENATOR JOSH NEWMAN IS THE
FIRST TO BE RECONSIDERED. UNDER
THESE RULES THAT WERE CHANGED
MID PROCESS
ALTHOUGH A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
SIGNATURES WERE TURNED INTO
TRIGGER THE RECALL ELECTION DUE
TO SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTEEN.
AND ITS MID PROCESS CHANGES
CENTER NEWMAN'S CONSTITUENTS
ABILITY BE ABLE VOTE ON HIS
RECALL WOULD BE DELAYED UNTIL
JUNE TWENTY ODD JUNE FIFTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
STATEWIDE PRIMARY ELECTION
WITHOUT THESE OBSTRUCTIVE
CHANGES THE RECALL ELECTION
WOULD HAVE BEEN HELD IN OCTOBER
OR NOVEMBER. THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN A SPEEDY PROCESS AS
ASK FOR BY OUR CONSTITUTION.
ADDITIONALLY THE NEW RULES DID
NOT CHANGE THE INTENT OF THE
VOTERS TO RECALL THEIR SENATOR.
ONLY EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
OUT OF SEVENTY THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT VOTERS
WHO SIGNED THE PETITION RECALL
SENATOR NEWMAN WITHDREW THEIR
SIGNATURES.
SPIKE A WELL FUNDED CAMPAIGN.
TO RECRUIT WITHDRAWALS.
THIS WAS JUST ONE PERCENT OF THE
TOTAL SIGNATURES
A ON THE RECALL PETITION AND IT
DID NOT AFFECT THE AMOUNT OF
SIGNATURESNEEDED TO INITIATE
THE RECALL ELECTION.
THIS BILL WOULD RESTORE THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTIONS
A RIGHT TO A SPEEDY RECALL OF
ELECTED OFFICIALS ACCUSED OF
WRONGDOING. OR GET AND GIVEN THE
JUSTICE THAT THEY SEEK WITH ME
HERE TODAY IS IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE IS DAVID.
DEEP WALL FROM THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION.
WE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MISTER
HARPER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MORNING DAVID WILL FOOT THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BELL AND. MISTER HARPER I THINK
APTLY STATED WITH THE BILL DID
SOME MY REMARKS AGAIN BE PRETTY
HAVE BREAST CAN SIMPLE. LISTEN
TO CHANGE THE RULES OF THE GAME
AT HALFTIME REGARDING AN ACTIVE
RECALL IS INAPPROPRIATE AND IT
DOES NEGATIVELY INFRINGE UPON
THE DEMOCRATS DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS.
MEMBERS THERE WAS ABSOLUTELY NO
NEED
HE PUT THE HINDRANCES IN THE
RECALL PROCESS THAT S. B. ONE
SEVENTEEN DEAD THERE'S NO REASON
TO WAIT THIRTY DAYS.
TO PAUL SIGNATURES OFF BECAUSE
THERE'S ALREADY A PROCESS TO
PULL SIGNATURES OFF.
IF PEOPLE DECIDE THEY NO LONGER
WANT TO SUPPORT A RECALL
PETITION.
YOU KNOW THERE WAS NOT NO
REASON FOR ANY OF THE DELAYS PUT
IN PLACE WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
THE LAND THE RECALL BEYOND
OCTOBER FROM WASHED YEAR. TO NOW
JUNE OF THIS YEAR AND.
FOR THOSE REASONS ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE AT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRINGING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
YOU WANNA GRAB AB.
MOST HAVING TO GIVE A COURTESY
SECOND.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
MISS ARE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE COURTESY YEAH.
.
IN THIS CASE THIS THIS BILL
WOULD NOT AFFECT THE CURRENT
RECALL OF VERSES AT CENTER JOSH
KNEW
THAT RECALL WILL TAKE PLACE ON
JUNE FIFTH. AYE AND UNLIKE A
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTEEN THE
CHANGES TO THE RECALL PROCESS
UNDER THIS BILL AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE WILL AFFECT FUTURE
RECALLS NOT THE CURRENT ONE.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THOSE WHO
SPOKE BEFORE THE COMMITTEE THE
RECENT CHANGES TO THE RECALL
PROCESS I BELIEVE WERE WRONG AND
UNJUST AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE TO RESTORE. THE
RIGHT TO A SPEEDY RECALL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU MISTER HARPER.
IN THE CHANGES THAT WERE MADE
TO THE RECALL PROCESS IS PART OF
THE BUDGET LAST YEAR WERE
RESPONSE TO SERIOUS ABUSES TO
THAT PROCESS.
SO I'M NOT PREPARED AT THIS
POINT TO VOTE FOR EFFORTS TO
UNDO THOSE CHANGES AND AS A
RESULT I'M UNABLE TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN.
BERMAN NO HARPER AYE HARPER AYE
CALDERON.
LOW. LOW NO MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE WEBER.
WEBER KNOW THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
AND MISTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MOVE ON TO.
EITHER IN EXTRA BILLS YES I'LL
DO WHAT AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
TO THE NEXT ONE ON PILE ORDER
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS I'M HERE PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY TWO. THIS BILL REPEAL
LOOPHOLE THAT ALLOWS MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATIONS
TO AVOID DISCLOSED YOUR MARK
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS OF UP TO
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT THEY
SOLICIT FROM THEIR MEMBERS.
INSTEAD SUCH ORGANIZATIONS WOULD
BE SUBJECT TO THE SAME ONE
HUNDRED DOLLAR THRESHOLD FOR
DISCLOSURE THAT APPLIES TO EVERY
SINGLE OTHER ORGANIZATION.
CANDIDATE AND COMMITTEE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR PROHIBITS
PERSONS FROM COLLECTING CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR THE PURPOSES
PARTICULAR CANDIDATE. UNLESS THE
IDENTITIES OF THE CONTRIBUTORS
ARE DISCLOSED IN THAT DOCUMENT.
ACCORDINGLY PERSONS OR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SELECTION
SOLICIT SUCH EARMARKED
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM OTHERS MUST
DISCLOSE THE IDENTITIES OF
CONTRIBUTORS TO GIVE ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS OR MORE.
FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION HAS NOTED THAT THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT BANDS
EARMARKED CONTRIBUTIONS WITHOUT
DISCLOSURE OF THE TRUE SOURCE OF
THE FUNDS.
BECAUSE THEY COULD DEPRIVE THE
PUBLIC OF IMPORTANT INFORMATION
OF WHO IS DONATING TO CAMPAIGNS
AND BECAUSE THEY FACILITATE THE
UNLAWFUL CIRCUMVENTION OF
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION LIMITS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA DISCLOSURE. TO
INCREASE THE DISCLOSURE OF THE
IDENTITIES OF GROUPS THAT PAPER
POLITICAL ADS
IRONICALLY THE ACT ALSO
DECREASED
THE DISCLOSURE OF PERSONS WHO
MAY LAW UNDER CONTRIBUTIONS
THROUGH MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATIONS.
BY RAISING THE DISCLOSURE
CULTURAL FOR SUCH PERSONS FROM
ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS
SPECIFICALLY IT STATED THAT
EARMARKED EMBARK PAYMENTS OF UP
TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS ARE
GIVEN BY PERSONS TO THEIR UNION.
OR MY OTHER MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION FOR THE PURPOSE
A BEING TRANSMITTED TO A
CANDIDATE OR BALLOT MEASURE
COMMITTEE SHALL NOT BE EARMARKED
AND THEREFORE SHALL NOT BE
DISCLOSED BY THE ORGANIZATION.
A. F. PPC REPORT NOTED THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DISCLOSE ACT CREATED
EIGHT WHOM TRACK DISCLOSURE
SYSTEM FOR EARMARKED
CONTRIBUTIONS
WERE MEMBER OR MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING UNIONS
ORGANIZED LABOR. ONLY HAVE TO
DISCLOSE DONORS AT BUT THAT FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR THRESHOLD.
WELL OTHER ALL OTHER POLITICAL
COMMITTEES HAVE TO DISCLOSURE
CONTRIBUTORS AT THE ONE HUNDRED
DOLLAR LEVEL.
SUCH LOOPHOLES ALLOW PERSONS TO
EVADE CONTRIBUTION LIMITS BY
GIVING THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT
DIRECTLY TO A CANDIDATE AND THEN
POTENTIALLY LAUNDERING AN
ADDITIONAL CONTRIBUTION OF UP TO
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR THE
SAME CANDIDATE. THROUGH THE
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION WITHOUT
THEIR IDENTITIES EVEN BEING
DISCLOSED.
AS NOTED BY THE F. PPC ANALYSIS
OF A SIMILAR BILL NO RATIONAL
EXPLANATION HAS BEEN PROVIDED TO
CREATE SUCH A SIGNIFICANT
LOOPHOLE TO CONTRIBUTION LIMITS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY TWO WILL DECREASE DARK
MONEY.
IN CALIFORNIA ELECTIONS AND MAKE
IT HARDER TO LAUNDER CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS BY REPEALING CLOSE
THE IDENTITIES OF PERSONS
WHO MAKE EARMARKED. POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS OF ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS OR MORE JUST LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE
WITH ME HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE. OR I'M SORRY TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY TWO IS DAVID WALL
FROM THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS YES SOME
BACKDATED WOLF WITH BARRY JARVIS
TAXPAYERS SAY SHE NEVER LEFT I'D
STROKE.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
HERE TODAY AS WELL.
AND MEMBERS WE WERE BROADLY EVEN
THOUGH WE OPPOSED AB TWO FORTY
NINE LAST YEAR MR MULLIN BUT WE
WERE BROADLY IN SUPPORT OF I
THINK MANY MANY PIECES IN THIS
BILL AND. YOU KNOW MISTER HARPER
REFERENCES ONE PIECE THAT WE
WERE OPPOSED TO FOR THE SIMPLE
REASON OF IF WE'RE GONNA HAVE
DISCLOSURE. LET'S HAVE
DISCLOSURE.
YOU KNOW WHY IT IS AVERAGE WIDER
AVERAGE EVERYDAY PEOPLE HAVE TO
DISCLOSE THAT HUNDRED DOLLARS
BUT MEMBERSHIP ASSOCIATIONS AS
MISTER HARPER MENTION WHICH
INCLUDES.
YOU KNOW LABOR PUBLIC COMPLAIN
LABOR UNIONS HAVE TO DISCLOSE
ITS FUN AT FIVE HUNDRED WHY NOT
HAVE THE SAME STANDARD ACROSS
THE BOARD THAT'S GOING TO LEAD
TO A DECREASE IN DARK MONEY AS
MR HARPER SAT. AND MEMBERS THAT
IS FAIR DISCLOSURE THAT'S ALL WE
WANT HER CELL ASK FOR NUMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING A FEW
.
GO AHEAD.
BUT THE TRAVELING PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN SPONSOR OF A AB TWO
FORTY NINE.
WE WE CERTAINLY DO NOT WANT TO
AN INCREASE IN THE MONEY
LAUNDERING.
OPPORTUNITIES OR OR LESSEN
DISCLOSURE THAT IS THE ACT
ABSOLUTE OPPOSITE A.
PURPOSE OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS ACT LAST YEAR I'M WE DO
BELIEVE HOWEVER THAT THIS THIS
PARTICULAR.
CHANGE WOULD BE ILL ADVISED FOR
DOING SO FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS.
I'M A FIRST OF ALL.
.
IT IS IT IS NOT A ALLOWING.
LAUNDERING OF CONTRIBUTIONS IT
ONLY APPLIES TO MEMBER DUES FEES
AND ASSESSMENTS AS THE ASSEMBLY
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THOSE ARE
SIMPLY MANDATORY CONTRIBUTIONS.
A A A MEMBERS OF IT MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATIONS CAN OPT OUT BUT
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT THEY DO
ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS. OF MORE
IMPORTANTLY IS IS THE A.
I AM ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL EXTRA BURDENS BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY. A.
DOING RAISING THAT THRESHOLD
WOULD ALLOW FOR THE POSSIBILITY
OF THE MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION
ITSELF. BEETLE LABOR UNION OR
ANY OTHER MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION.
THEM THEMSELVES NOT BEING
DISCLOSED ON ADS AS THIS IS THE
PURPOSE OF THE DISCLOSE ACT
BECAUSE THE CONTRIBUTIONS
WOULDN'T BE. A EARMARKED FROM
THEM THEY'D BE HERE MARK FROM
THE ORIGINAL MEMBERS OF CAPE TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
ON THAT. A A IT DOES NOT. AND I
THINK THERE MAY BE MISREADING IT
DOES NOT SAY THAT THOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS AREN'T CONSIDERED
YOUR MARKETS AS IT IS. SAYS AND
I THINK IT'S BEEN INTERPRETED BY
A PPC REGULATIONS TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT THOSE ARE CONSIDERED AS
YOUR MARK FROM. THE MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION ITSELF SO.
THAT IS WHY THIS WOULD ACTUALLY
WILL LESSEN THE DISCLOSURE IN
CASES LIKE IN THE A A COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS DONE.
IT WOULD CAUSE NOBODY TO BE
DISCLOSED BECAUSE NONE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS AGAPE TO
INNER DOLLARS GOING TO REACH THE
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR THRESHOLD.
INTO WOULD MEAN THAT THE
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION ITSELF
WOULD NOT BE DISCLOSED ON ADS
THAT WOULD BE A MAJOR MISTAKE
FROM OUR POINT OF VIEW THEREFORE
WE ASK YOU OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TRISTEN BROWN
OF CALVET FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
JUST WANTED POINT OUT A COUPLE
THINGS IN OPPOSITION HERE'S THAT
ONE.
.
WHAT WE KNOW WHAT THIS A PORTION
OF DISCLOSE ACT WAS A CAREFULLY
NEGOTIATED AND WELL BALANCED
TEST THAT?
WAS UNDER MUCH SCRUTINY WHEN
THE DISCLOSE ACT WAS PASSED. OF
THE REASON FOR IT BEING OF
COURSE THAT MEMBERSHIP BASED
ORGANIZATIONS CONSISTENTLY ARE
ATTEMPTING TO FUND RAISE FOR
THEIR POLITICAL ACTION.
MEMBERS
HE ACTUALLY HAS VOLUNTARILY DO
CONTRIBUTE TO THESE ARE
POLITICAL ACTION FUNDS THE
SPONSORED COMMITTEES AND THEY DO
SO PREMIERED OF REASONS BUT
MOSTLY TO ADVANCE THE CAUSE OF
WHATEVER MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION
THEY ALL BELONG TO SO YES IN THE
IN THE LEAD. INSTANCE OF A STATE
TEACHERS UNION AYE IT WOULD BE
FOR THE PROTECTION OF PROP
NINETY EIGHT AND ANOTHER LABOR
STANDARDS IT SAID ABOUT THAT
ARE.
A BELIEF SHARED BY ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THAT ORGANIZATION AS
THE CHIP IN MONTHLY SAY A MODEST
AMOUNT OF TEN DOLLARS PER MONTH
THEY MIGHT RISE UP TO AN AMOUNT
THAT IS GREATER THAN A HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
I AT WHICH POINT IT IS NICE TO
POINT OUT THAT ON THE US
SPONSORING ORGANIZATIONS FOR
SIXTY.
ANYONE WHO DOES CONTRIBUTE TO A
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEE OVER
HUNDRED DOLLARS ARE ITEMIZED AS
CONTRIBUTORS AND SO THERE IS A
WAY TO FIND THIS INFORMATION IT
IS ALREADY DISCLOSED. THAT DOES
NOT MEAN THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE GIVEN FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ULTIMATELY AFFECTING A AS.
THE.
I GUESS AND RESULT THE RECIPIENT
COMMITTEES CONTRIBUTION AND SO
IF OF COMMUNICATION GOES OUT AS
THEY PERIODICALLY DUE TO RALLY
THE TROOPS AND SAY LET'S ALL
COME TOGETHER. PLEASE CHIP IN TO
YOUR POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEE
SO THAT WE CAN.
ELECT OF THE FAMOUS CANDIDATE
ACTS OF WAR CONTINUE TO FIGHT
AGAINST BALLOT MEASURE WISE AND
AND.
IN ADDICTS AND I GUESS YOU SPUR
AN EXAMPLE AS A RALLYING CALL
NOT NECESSARILY THAT ALL OF YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE DIRECTLY
GOING.
TWO CANDIDATE ACTS ABOUT MEASURE
WHY I IT IS JUST MUCH EASIER AND
I'VE MUCH TRUER TO SAY. THESE
BOOKS ARE CONTRIBUTING TO THE
PURPOSE OF PROTECTING THE
SPONSORING COMMITTEE NOT GIVING
TO THE AS AN INTERMEDIARY AND AS
AN EARMARK CONTRIBUTION TO THE.
RECIPIENT COMMITTEE.
AND SO DOING SO IF WE WERE TO
LOWER THE SPECIAL FROM FIVE
HUNDRED TO ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS
ALL OF THESE CONTRIBUTIONS WILL
BE YOUR MARK PERHAPS IN A WAY
THAT IT'S FORCE ASSOCIATION THAT
IS NOT INTENDED BY THE ACTUAL
CONTRIBUTOR. AYE AND IS. A
COSTLY.
IT I GUESS SCHEME THAT VAN
WOULD BE.
SO IT WOULD COST SO MUCH TO THE
SPONSORING ORGANIZATION THAT
THEY WERE NO LONGER BE EFFECTIVE
I ENABLE TO COMPLY WITH WITH THE
NEW REGULATION AND THUS RENDER
THEIR SPEECH.
EARLY I GET CHILL THEIR SPEECH
TO A POINT WHERE NOW ONLY THE
VERY WELL FUNDED INTEREST COULD
ACTUALLY TAKE PART. IN IN THE
POLITICAL DISCOURSE SO THAT IS
WHY THERE WAS A GREAT BALLOTS
STRUCK FOR FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
AND NOT THE ONE HUNDRED LEVEL
AND AGAIN ALL OF THOSE
CONTRIBUTORS OVER ONE HUNDRED.
DO END UP ON A FOR SIXTY AT THE
END OF THE DAY AND EVERYONE CAN
AND THERE'S FULL DISCLOSURE OF
THAT INFORMATION SO IT'S FOR
THESE REASONS THAT WE WE ARE AS
FOR A. A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL
AND KEEP THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF
THE DISCLOSE ACT HOLE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MICHELLE CAST OF THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION FOR THE REASONS STATED BY
THE TWO PREVIOUS WITNESSES WHERE
POST THANK YOU THANK YOU.
A SONG OR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE
ARE ALSO IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU.
MUCH TIGHTER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN A
POSITION THAT YOU'RE MUCH.
PACMAN WITHIN READING ASSOCIATES
REPEALING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEGE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS
MR ROTH OBERNOLTE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE CELL.
I I THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL I'M
USUALLY ALWAYS IN FAVOR OF A
GREATER DISCLOSURE AND I
ACTUALLY FIND IT SOMEWHAT IRONIC
THAT THE CROWDS OF PEOPLE THAT
WERE IN THIS CHAMBER. COUPLE
MINUTES AGO AS WE HEARD ANOTHER
BILL. THAT I ADVOCATED FOR
GREATER DISCLOSURE NOT HEAR
CLAMORING FOR GREATER DISCLOSURE
IN THIS CASE BECAUSE.
IN I THINK IT'S A IT'S TWO
SIDES OF THE SAME POINT.
I ALSO WANTED TO SAY THAT I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
HOWARD JARVIS IS HERE SUPPORTING
THE BILL BECAUSE THEY ARE ALSO A
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION AND SO.
ARE FOR THEM TO BE SAYING PLEASE
WE WOULD LIKE GREATER DISCLOSURE
LIMITS APPLY TO US I THINK IS
REALLY COMPELLING SO I'M A HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL AYE DUH. AYE
MOVE THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION THAT WE
HAVE A SECOND.
ARE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
MISTER HARPER WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE MEASURE.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD
LIKE TO I THINK THOSE WHO SPOKE
UP BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
.
LOOPHOLES THAT ALLOW FOR LARGE
AMOUNTS OF DARK MONEY TO BE
DONATED THE CAMPAIGNS SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED. AND I SAY
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH ONE
OF THE COMMENTS PROP BY THE
OPPOSITION I DO NOT THINK THE
TRANSPARENCY IS A SCHEME.
THERE SHOULD BE A UNIVERSAL
CONTRIBUTION DISCLOSURE OF ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS APPLY TO ALL
WITH EQUAL PROTECTION UNDER THE
LAW.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WEREN'T I
VOTE FOR THIS BILL. AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TWO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A AND WHILE
I UNDERSTAND OF THE AUTHOR AND
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL SEE THE
PRISON IT SEE THIS PROVISION OF
THE DISCLOSE ACT DEALING WITH
MEMBERSHIP DUES AND FEES. TO BE
SOME SORT OF LOOPHOLE THE IN
FACT THE EXACT OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
THAT PROVISION ACTUALLY
PREVENTS A LOOPHOLE WHICH WOULD
STOP.
WHETHER IT'S A LABOR
ORGANIZATION OR THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION OR
THE NATIONAL RIFLE RIFLE
ASSOCIATION FROM BEING LISTED ON
ADS.
AND THAT WOULD CREATE LESS
DISCLOSURE FOR VOTERS TO KNOW
WHICH ORGANIZATION
ARE TRYING TO INFLUENCE.
THEIR DECISION AND WHAT VOTE
THEY MAKE AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT.
AND AS THE CALVET THE MONEY
CAMPAIGN IS TESTIFIED THE
ENACTMENT OF THIS BILL WOULD
UNDERMINE THE PURPOSES OF THE
DISCLOSE ACT.
BY INCREASING THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT A MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION
WILL BE LEFT OFF THE LIST OF TOP
FUNDERS THAT MUST APPEAR ON
ADVERTISEMENT'S UNDER THE
DISCLOSE ACT. SO NOT PREPARED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND RECOMMEND
AND OPPOSED POSITION.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CULTURAL
AND THE MOTIONS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN KNOW
BERMAN NO HARPER AYE HARPER AYE
CALDERON.
LOW.
NO NO MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE WEBER.
WEBER NOW.
SO THAT BILLS ON CALL.
IN VICE ARE EVER OF YOU LIKE TO
MOVE ON DE. AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY THREE THINK IT FOR MY
THIRD OF THREE BILL
PRESENTATIONS HOPEFULLY WE CAN
GET A YES VOTE THE EFFORTS REAL.
ABOUT THAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I AM HERE TO PRESENT TO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE I TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY THREE OF WHICH IS TO
REQUIRE BALLOT HARVESTERS WHO
COLLECT BOAT BUT VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS.
TO PROVIDE A RECEIPT
TO THE VOTER UPON REQUEST
IDENTIFYING WHO IS PICKING UP
THEIR BALLOT. IN THE PAST VOTERS
WERE ALLOWED TO DESIGNATE THEIR
TRUSTED FAMILY MEMBERS AND
ROOMMATES ARE TO RETURN TO THEIR
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT ALSO KNOWN
AS A BBM DEL ON THEIR BEHALF.
PRIOR LAW SPECIFICALLY
PROHIBITED CAMPAIGN WORKERS OR
OTHER SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS
FROM COLLECTING VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS FROM VOTERS.
A TACTIC KNOWN AS BALLOT
HARVESTING IN ORDER TO PREVENT
VOTER CRUSH POTENTIAL VOTER
PORTION FRAUD AND NON DELIVERED
BALLOTS.
HOWEVER THE LEGISLATURE RECENTLY
REPEAL THOSE RESTRICTIONS AND
PROVIDED INSTEAD THAT ANY GROUP
INCLUDING CAMPAIGN WORKERS AND
SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS MAY NOW
GO DOOR TO DOOR HARVESTING VOTE
BY MAIL BALLOTS.
FROM VOTERS.
UNFORTUNATELY WITH THE
LEGALIZATION OF BELT HARVESTING
THEIR NOW OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CAMPAIGN OPERATIVES TO INTERFERE
IN OUR ELECTIONS.
IN THE FIRST ASSEMBLY ELECTION
AFTER BALLOT HARVESTING WAS
LEGALIZED THERE WERE PUBLISHED
REPORTS OF OVERLY AGGRESSIVE
BALLOT HARVESTERS HARVESTING IN
COURSING VOTERS.
TO HAND IN THEIR BALLOTS.
IT WHICH REVEALED.
WHICH CANDIDATE THEY WERE
VOTING FOR.
WE HAVE TO WONDER WHY DID THAT
BALLOT HARVESTER ASK WHO THE
VOTER VOTED FOR. WITH THE
HARVEST FIRST THEY'LL DELIVER
THE BALLOT IF THE VOTER VOTED
FOR THE WRONG CANDIDATE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW.
IT THE BALLOT HARVESTER DOES NOT
DELIVER THE VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT
TO THE POLLS AND THEREBY
DISENFRANCHISE IS THE VOTER
THERE IS NOT A WAY FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS TO TRACK
DOWN THE PERSON.
DOWN FOR CRIMINAL PROSECUTION.
NO WAY OF BEING ABLE TO FIND NO
PAPER TRAIL. IN RESPONSE.
THESE BELT HARVESTING ABUSES THE
LOS ANGELES TIMES PUBLISHED IN
OUR IN EDITORIAL ENTITLED DON'T
ALLOW VOTER CORE XIN AND
CORRUPTION TO TAKE HOLD IN
CALIFORNIA.
NOTING THAT VOTER PROTECTIONS
NEEDED TO BE PUT IN PLACE AND
THAT LAWMAKERS SHOULD REASSESS
THE WISDOM OF ALLOWING UNKNOWN
THIRD PARTIES TO COLLECT BALLOTS
FROM VOTERS.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THEIR
CONCERNS
BY REQUIRING CANVASSERS.
TO GIVE VOTERS A DETAILED
RECEIPT VOTERS WILL FEEL MORE
SECURE IN HANDING OVER THEIR
BALLOT.
THIS ADDED ACCOUNTABILITY WOULD
DISCOURAGE ELECTION FRAUD AND
ALLOW AUTHORITIES TO IDENTIFY
ANYONE WHO INTERFERES WITH AN
ABSENTEE BALLOT. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY THREE WILL
PROTECT VOTERS BY ENSURING THAT
THEIR VOTE IS COUNTED. AND THAT
NO ONE DISENFRANCHISE THEM BY
FAILING TO DELIVER THEIR BALLOT
TO THE ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
AGAIN WITH ME HERE TODAY. IS MY
GOOD FRIEND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
ASSEMBLY BILL DAVID WALL FROM
THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I FEEL
LITTLE BIT RIGHT NOW LIKE GUY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
APPROPRIATIONS HEARING.
BAILEY.
RIGHT. NOW BUT I DO HAVE A FILE
ON THIS BILL MEMBERS AND THAT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT TODAY OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY TERRY.
AND IT SHOULD BE NOTED MEMBERS
THAT WE DID OPPOSE THE BELL.
THAT LED TO THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY MUCH AS WE DID WITH THE
OTHER TWO BILLS THE MISTER
HARPER PRESENTED SO WERE ON
OBVIOUSLY GOOD PRECEDENT GOOD
GROUNDS TO BE HERE TODAY.
MEMBERS WERE OBVIOUSLY NOT.
IN FAVOR OF DISCOURAGING THEIR
DISENFRANCHISEMENT VOTERS IN ANY
WAY.
I SPEAK TO YOUR HAIR YOU KNOW
AS SOMEONE WITH A DISABILITY FOR
WHICH AN ABSENTEE BALLOT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL.
YOU KNOW PREVIOUS LA BEFORE.
YOU KNOW THE PROVISIONS THAT
WERE SEEKING TO REPEAL WERE IN
PLACE ALLOWED FOR FAMILY MEMBERS
AND THOSE LIVING IN THE SAME
RESIDENTS TOGETHER TO TURN IN
THESE ABSENTEE BALLOTS AND. YOU
KNOW WE THOUGHT THAT WAS
COMPLETELY FAIR AND APPROPRIATE
AND ESPECIALLY FOR SENIORS AND
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE DISABLED.
YOU KNOW TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE
THE BALLOTS WERE COUNTED IN A
TIMELY MANNER. BUT NOW THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ANYONE BEING
ABLE TO TURN IN THESE BALLOTS
NOT JUST ANYONE BEING ABLE TO
TURN THE MEN BUT INCREASINGLY
BEING ABLE TO TURN AND I'M AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF BALLOTS IN
TEXAS AT LEAST WHEN IT SAID I
THINK. TO TEN ABSENTEE BALLOTS
THAT SOMEONE CAN TURN IT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AN UNLIMITED
NUMBER OF BALLOTS HERE. THERE IS
CERTAINLY IS AS MR HARPER
MENTIONED AT THE POTENTIAL FOR
FRAUD.
.
YOU KNOW AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE NOT OUT WE'RE NOT
OUTLINED THIS PROCESS BROUGHT
FORWARD IN IN THE PREVIOUS BILL
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS THERE NEEDS
TO BE A RECEIPT.
AND THAT RECEIPT IS GOING TO
PROVIDE PEACE OF MIND NOT ONLY
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL THAT GIVES
THEIR BALLOT TO SOMEONE TO TURN
IN FOR THEM. BUT ALSO I THINK TO
COUNTY REGISTRARS TO BE ABLE TO
AGAIN AS MR HARPER SAID TO HAVE
A PAPER TRAIL GOING FORWARD SO
WE KNOW HE'S TURNING IN THESE
BALLOTS AND WE CAN CATCH.
MALFEASANCE IF IT HAPPENS
SO I THINK THIS IS A COMPLETELY
RATIONAL BILL ASK FOR ANOTHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
RICHARD CHAIRMAN OF THE VOTING
RIGHTS TASK FORCE YES WE
CONSIDER OF THE VOTE BY MAIL TO
BE HAVE A VERY WEAK CHAIN OF
CUSTODY SO. ALL WE'RE DOING IS
GIVING RECEIPTS OF THE VOTERS
WHO ASK FOR IT AND I. OF OUR OUR
GROUP OF VOTED UNANIMOUSLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
WE HAD A VERY MODEST.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ME WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
HOPE.
SO.
OR NEUTRAL. NOT NEW TROLLED NOT
FULLY OPPOSING WE HAVE A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION AKA
THEY LOOK FOR THE OPTION. THIS
IS THAT ONE OF HOUSING WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH
THE WITNESS HERE SO PROVIDE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WE
COUNT ON OF THE PEOPLE TO TURN
OUR ABOUT.
OFTENTIMES IT'S FAMILY MEMBERS
OFTENTIMES IT'S KICK CAREGIVERS.
AND IF WE REQUIRE THE CAREGIVERS
IN THE CIRCLE OF SUPPORT TO FILL
OUT THESE RECEIPTS.
THEY MAY NOT WANT TO BE.
.
REQUIRED TO FILL OUT ALL THAT
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION WHICH
THEN WEAKENS THE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT THE PEOPLE DISABILITIES
HAVE.
AND THEN THEY DON'T HAVE THE ONE
TO HELP THEM TO TURN IN THEIR
BALLOT HAVE THEIR VOTE COUNTED.
SO WE HAVE REQUESTED IN AN
AMENDMENT I THINK IT'S.
LAID OUT WELL IN THE ANALYSIS
BUT WITHOUT THAT AMENDMENT WE
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS BOOK BILL
FULLY SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE ANY MORE
OPPOSITION IN SUPPORT OF AMENDED
NEWS ROLE.
SUPPORT.
YEAH PLEASE MY ANGER AND
LEGISLATIVE ATTORNEY WITH THE
ACLU CALIFORNIA WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL LOOKS WE THINK
IT CRAFTSMAN AND PERFECT REMEDY
TO AN UNVERIFIED PROBLEM. AS THE
ANALYSIS LAYS OUT CURRENT LAW
ALREADY PROVIDES FOR A VARIETY
OF SAFEGUARDS AND PUNISHMENTS TO
ADDRESS VOTER FRAUD AND ABUSE IN
THE VOTE BY MAIL CONTACTS.
THERE WAS MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
IS BELL IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AB
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE. FAR YOU
KNOW FRAUD IMITATION TAMPA
TAMPERING WITH VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS ALL HAVE CRIMINAL
PENALTIES WERE UNAWARE OF VOTE.
LARGE SCALE OR ANY PROBLEM OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I'M BEING UNABLE TO TRACK DOWN
INDIVIDUALS WHO COMMIT THAT WITH
RESPECT TO BOTH BY MAIL BALLOTS
WE THINK THE RECEIPT AS DESIGNED
IN THIS BILL IS FLAWED FOR ONE
IT REQUIRES. THE RETURNING
INDIVIDUAL DISCS LESS THEIR
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR CALIFORNIA
ID NUMBER. AND THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S EVEN REQUIRED
TO VOTE MANY PEOPLE IN THIS.
STAY IN COUNTRY DON'T HAVE
GOVERNMENT ISSUED IDENTIFICATION
THEY ARE ELDERLY LOW INCOME
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THAT CAN AFFORD TO GET THIS.
LICENSE OR FOR THE UNDERLYING
DOCUMENTATION TO GET IT.
TWENTY A TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SURVEY FOUND THAT ELEVEN PERCENT
OF US CITIZENS DON'T HAVE
GOVERNMENT ISSUED PHOTO ID.
WE ALSO THINK ITS FLAWED BECAUSE
IT REQUIRES.
A SIGNIFICANT AND PRIVACY
INTRUSION IN THAT IT REQUIRES
THE PERSON TO LESS THEIR HOME
ADDRESS AND I'M RATHER THAN THE
ORGANIZATIONAL ADDRESS. AND ALSO
FAILS TO FIGURE OUT HOW A PERSON
WILL BE NOTIFIED OF THEIR
AFFIRMATIVE DUTY TO OFFER AND
PROVIDE THIS RECEIPT AND. WHAT
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO RECEIVES SAID
WHAT ACTUALLY DO WITH THE AND
HOW THAT WOULD END UP MATCHING
UP WITH THE?
I INVESTIGATION OF SUCH A CLAIM
SO FOR THOSE REASONS AND THE
FLAWS AS THE AND THE BUTLER
SPARKLY ASTORINO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE REMEMBER COLLEAGUES
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS MOTIONS
SECONDS.
THANK
GOT A MOTION AND A SECOND.
MISTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
I.
I THINK THE POINT WAS THAT
BROUGHT UP A BY THE OPPOSITION.
CAN'T VERIFY THE PROBLEM WITHOUT
THE RECEIPT.
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT.
YOU NEED TO HAVE THE PAPER TRAIL
TO HAVE PEOPLE TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THE VOTE.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT FOLKS
WITHOUT ID'S OR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS HERE WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. IS ORGANIZED BALLOT
HARVESTING BY SOPHISTICATED
POLITICAL OPERATIONS UP WHICH
MAY BE DISCARDING VOTES OR MAYBE
PRESSURING PEOPLE'S VOTES LIKE
IT'S SOME KIND OF UNION CARD
CHECK COLLECTION.
I UNDERSTAND THAT SOME PEOPLE
WOULD LIKE FOR THIS PROCESS
I TO BE THE CASE BECAUSE OF
THEIR UP POLITICAL TENDENCIES
AND BECAUSE OF THE WAY THEY
WOULD LIKE THE.
THE ELECTRIC TO BE REFLECTED
DIE IN FAVOR OF THEIR UP
POLITICAL IDEALS. BUT THIS
SHOULD BE A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
FOR ALL.
THE ELECT BALLOT SHOULD HAVE
INTEGRITY.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE TO KNOW
WHO IS CARRYING ON THEIR BACK
AYE CARING THEIR BALLOT. AND A
BUNCH OF BALLOTS GET DUMPED ON
TO THE RETRO VOTERS THE RETRO
VOTER SHOULD KNOW WHERE IT'S A
IT'S A IS A COMING FROM AS WELL.
THESE KINDS OF SYSTEMS ARE GOING
TO BE RIGHT.
TAMMANY HALL STYLE.
MODIFICATIONS AND INTERFERENCE
IN OUR ELECTIONS.
LET'S HAVE THE RECEIPT.
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO IT'S
THE LOOPHOLE VICTOR VICTOR WAS
NOT PLUGIN THAT WAS IDENTIFIED
BY NGUYEN IS A SAID THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES HAD ITSELF OPERA.
BALLOT CORE XIN CORRUPTION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA LET'S
AVOID IT LET'S STOP IT LET'S
NIPPED IN THE BUD LET'S HAVE A
RECEIPT. PLEASE VOTE FOR A. B.
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER ARBOR.
AND WHILE IT WAS A PLEASURE.
TO SUPPORT A HUNDRED PERCENT OF
YOUR BILLS AT THE LAST HEARING.
I MUST OPPOSE A HUNDRED PERCENT
OF YOUR BILLS AT THIS HEARING.
ASIDE FROM THE LOGISTICAL
ISSUES PRESENTED BY THIS BILL
I'M UNSURE HOW VOTER FRAUD OF
THIS TYPE WOULD BE PREVENTED BY
REQUIRING IT DOESN'T NEED TO
PROVIDE A VOTE BY MAIL VOTER
WITH A RECEIPT. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I'LL BE VOTING NO AND
RECOMMENDING AND OPPOSE POSITION
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN NO BERMAN
NO HARPER. AYE HARPER AYE
CALDERON.
LOW.
LOW NO MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE WEBER.
WEBER NOW.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL THANK YOU
CHAIR WITH THREE FOR THREE BE
CONSIDERED A HAT TRICK THERE
WOULD BE.
HOCKEY BASEBALL. ANYTHING.
.
OKAY LET'S LET'S GO AHEAD LIVE
CALLS INTO VOTE ADD ONS WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR A ABSENT
AUTHORS PLEASE. CALL THE AUTHORS
I KNOW WHERE ONE OF THEM IS I
HAVE NO IDEA WHERE ANOTHER ONE
OF THEM IS.
.
TO GET THEM HERE.
SO.
WILL YOU I'M WEAK PHRASES OPEN
THE CALL. LOOK THE CALL WE LOOK
EVERY TWO TO THREE ONE.
LOW.
AND LET ME SAY I ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB TWO TO THREE ONE.
IS
BECAUSE I MEAN TO THE VOTE NOW
IT IS AS TO TWO WITH A NO
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
SO THAT'S A PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AGAIN MR LOW IS NOT VOTING.
MULLIN.
WEBER.
WEBER NOW.
SO THAT'S STILL ON CALL. A ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB TWO ZERO FIVE ONE
HAS A TO TO TO VOTE AND THE.
CHAIR RECOMMENDATION IS NOW.
CALDERON.
LOW.
LOW IS NO MULLIN.
THAT.
THAT'S STILL ON CALL ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY TWO.
IT'S A THREE TWO VOTE WITH THE
CHAIR RECOMMENDED AIR WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING YES.
CALDERON.
MULLIN.
THAT ACCOMPLISH NOTHING.
I THINK WE ARE TRYING.
AND I'M GUESSING ON THESE NEXT
THREE SO WE'VE DONE ALL WE CAN
ON THAT FRONT.
.
TO NOW MOVE ON TO ADD ONS FOR
THE BILLS THAT ARE ALREADY OUT.
DID PLEASE JUST GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE LESS OKAY I'M CAN
SENSE.
MISTER HARPER.
BY MISTER HARPER'S AYE AND MR
LOW.
LOW AYE
.
ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT BY
MISTER MARLAND PARA IN THE
MOTION WAS TO PROCESS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO COMMITTEE AND
APPROACHED.
I'M CALLED A ROOM.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE IS NOW.
I ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTY TWO YEAR BY MR LOW TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROACHES.
AND CALDERON.
MULLIN.
IT'S ALREADY OUT. ITS JUST AT A
NON.
I'M MULLIN AS I ONE WE PAUSE
THEM FOR NOW. LOOKS GOOD.
I'VE.
I NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY FIVE
ALSO RELATES TO LAST YEAR'S IT
AGAIN FOUR NINE THE DISCLOSE
ACT.
THERE A NUMBER OF TECHNICAL
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN THAT REGARD
DEFINITIONS AND OTHER VERY MINOR
ISSUES I WOULD SIMPLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THIS IS A DEFINITIONS
THAT ADVERTISEMENT MASS
ELECTRONIC MAILING AND MASS
MAILING AS WELL AS SOME
ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATION ON
FORMATTING AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND THEN JUST TO
CONFIRM YOUR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AROUND THE ANALYSIS
THANK YOU. SIR.
ANY WITNESSES IN QUICK SUPPORT.
A PROCLAIM PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN THESE ARE.
IMPORTANT MINOR A CURFEW
CATIONS AB TWO FORTY NINE SO WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL BONUSES AND
SUPPORT.
LEE LAWRENCE WHIPPLE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
JACK BUT NO COMMON CAUSE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I'LL BRING IT BACK
TO COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
BUT YOU'RE A BURKE.
ANY CHANCE WE.
AND THEN REJECTED AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY TWO AND.
A.
THAT IS AN UNFRIENDLY AMENDMENTS
YEAH.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE MISTER MALONE YOUR
TO CLOSE.
IF WE ASK FOR A VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
.
OF THIS IS GOOD AND I RECOMMEND
AN AYE VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THEN MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE CALDERON. LOW. LOW
AYE MULLIN AYE MULLIN AYE
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE AND
WEBER.
WEBER I THE GREAT THAT BILLOWS
OUT WILL LEAVE THE OF ALL OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO.
WE HAVE BEEN UNABLE.
TO LOCATE.
MISTER ALAN SO WE ARE NOT GOING
TO HEAR. ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY TWO WAS ALSO
LOOKING FOR THE HEARING FOR.
THE SECOND TIME.
AND AND A LOT OF US WERE
LOOKING FOR TO HEARING IT.
AND COMMENTING.
IS SO WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO.
LIFT THE CALL.
ON THE REMAINING BILLS.
OKAY ITEM SIX ON AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY ONE BY MR PEROT.
MULLIN.
EXCUSE ME IT'S.
AND.
SO THIS I'M NUMBER SIX.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS JUDITH
THREE WITH A NO RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE CHAIR.
MULLIN.
NO.
SO NEXT IS A.
IS THAT FAILS.
AND WE WILL.
THAT THEY'LL.
REALLY LOOKING FOR THE.
YEAH.
ALRIGHT SO WE'RE GOOD.
I'M NUMBER ONE ABTWENTY FIFTY
ONE THE VOTE IS TWO TO THREE
WITH A. NO RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE CHAIR.
CALDERON.
NOT WHEN.
MULLIN NOW.
THAT BILL FAILS AND WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
.
I NEVER FOR AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY TWO.
THAT HAS A THREE TO TWO VOTE
WITH THE S. RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE CHAIR.
CALDERON.
MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
THAT'S OUT FORTY TWO WILL LEAVE
IT UP TO PRESS AND MEMBERS.
NEXT IS.
I REMEMBER FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY ONE VOTE IS
CURRENTLY TWO TO THREE WITH A NO
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
CALDERON.
MULLIN.
MISTER MULLIN ON. AND MULLIN
NOW.
THAT BILL FAILS TO THE FOR WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THE NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY TWO OF
THE CAR VOTERS TWO TO THREE WITH
A NO RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR.
CALDERON.
MULLIN.
MULLIN NOW.
THAT BILL FAILS TO TO FOR. OF
THE NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY THREE. OF
THE CURRENT VOTERS TO TO THREE
WITH A NO RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE CHAIR. CALDERON.
MULLIN.
MULLIN NOW.
THE BILL FAILS.
WHEN NOW LET'S.
.
THAT MEMBERS.
AND ON TO.
BILLS THEY WERE HERE FOR.
THERE WE GO.
AND SO I THINK EVERYBODY USE
HERE HAS VOTED. NO
STILL OPEN.
OKAY SO LET'S DISCUSSES ROLL
THROUGH OKAY.
ON ITEM TO AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
FIVE MISTER MULLIN.
NUMBER TWO.
MULLIN THIS I.
ON.
I NEVER GOT YOU THERE.
I AM MISTER MULLIN ON ITEM
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT PRIME MR CHOW.
MULLIN IS I.
ANON ITEM SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN BY
GIPSON MISTER MULLIN. MULLIN
AYE.
GREAT.
THIS CONFIRMS.
THANK YOU.
SO WE WILL WAIT FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS TO JOIN US IN THAT ON
WILL GIVE THEM FIVE MINUTES.
THAT WE DO GOVERNMENT IT'S A
PERFECT
JOINT.
RIGHT NOW.
SO.
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE.
GO THROUGH THE BILL SELECT
MEMBERS AT ON.
I AM.
ITEM ONE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIFTY ONE BY CHOICE CALDERON.
CALDERON NO.
ITEM THREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE FIFTY FIVE BY MULLIN
CALDERON. CALDERON AYE.
ITEM FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY TWO BY WEBER
CALDERON. CALDERON AYE.
I AM FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT BY MULLIN
CALDERON. CALDERON AYE.
ITEM SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE FIFTY TO BITE LOW
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE.
ITEM NINE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE FORTY CALDERON. CALDERON
AYE.
I DON'T THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT BY CHAO
CALDERON.
CALDERON I.
ITEM FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT.
HIS ME ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ANYONE BY HARPER CALDERON.
CULTURAL NO.
I AM FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY TWO BY
HARPER CALDERON. CALDERON NO.
ITEM SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY THREE BY
HARPER CALDERON. CALDERON NO.
THE REMEDY CIRCLED AROUND WITH
THAT THE MEETINGS ADJOURNED